un invité d'honneur en vue des
traditionnels qui participe toujours à
notre forum le président de la
fédération de russie vladimir poutine
devoucoux
vous
chers amis chères invitées
je suis ravi de vous voir à la session
finale du club de discussion valdaï
je voudrais vous présenter notre invité
le président de la fédération de russie
vladimir poutine
bonjour chers collègues
chers amis chers participants de cette
17ème session plénière du club valdaï
mesdames messieurs donc je commence pas
vous saluer pour cette rencontre
annuelle
cette année elle se déroule dans des
conditions inhabituelles en régime de
visioconférence évidemment les gens ne
sont pas disposées comme d'habitude mais
en tout cas ils sont là ils sont
présents dans la salle et on a toujours
cette possibilité de pouvoir discuter en
direct
nous comprenons tous bien que cette
épidémie de coronavirus a fortement
modifié notre vie sociale notre vie
personnelle et tout ce à quoi nous
sommes habitués tous les jours a dû
évoluer mais donc il ya ces ces
restrictions qui s'impose un peu partout
dans notre vie professionnelle dans
notre vie personnelle et cette année
donc a donc constituer une difficulté
particulière pour nous mais nous
continuons notre travail à l'aide des
technologies qui nous permettent de
communiquer à distance et d'avoir des
discussions des débats avec les experts
où chacun donne son avis cela nous
permet de discuter de façon inhabituelle
et d'examiner des avis qui peuvent être
différents contradictoires et cette
discussion est importante notamment dans
la politique surtout aujourd'hui où un
certain nombre de problèmes se posent
aujourd'hui qu'ils ont besoin de trouver
des solutions et nous avons encore à
réfléchir à l'avenir sur la façon dont
cette épidémie aura influencé la vie de
l'humanité la communauté internationale
et notamment celles communauté interne
et celles qui aujourd'hui essaient de se
mobiliser de prendre des mesures pour
lutter contre cette épidémie et donc des
mesures ont déjà été prises mais et nous
sommes bien conscients du fait que tous
ceux qui auraient dû être pris n'a pas
été pris les mesures nécessaires n'ont
pas toujours été prise et il ya eu des
opportunités qu'on a dû laisser passer
la russie dès le début a placé les
valeurs qui sont les siennes en priorité
dès le début c'est à dire la vie des
citoyens leur santé
ça a été la priorité que nous avons
fixée c'est aussi l'attachement à nos
valeurs culturelles historiques ne vous
savez quels sont les pertes
démographiques énorme que nous avons
subies au xxème siècle où chaque famille
a souffert chaque famille russe a
souffert dans sa chair est donc pour
nous la préservation de la santé de la
vie de nos concitoyens tout cela c'est
important et notamment de la génération
âgée de ceux qui ont perdu leur travail
et donc nous avons dès le début cherché
à réduire autant que possible ses
conséquences négatives pour la
population
et donc que nous avons travaillé au
niveau des entreprises des familles nous
avons été attentifs tous les jours à
l'évolution de cet ep d'amis le
coronavirus continue aujourd'hui à
constituer une menace importante et cela
constitue toujours une un fond
d'angoissé d'inquiétude qui demeure pour
l'ensemble de la société
ce n'est pas simplement que nous sommes
aujourd'hui au seuil de changement
considérable de mouvements tectoniques
mais nous voyons aussi que les processus
dont il a souvent été question
précédemment dans les autres éditions du
club valdaï
ces processus aujourd'hui évolué de
façon beaucoup plus rapide qu'attendu on
voit ces jeux qui ne respectent pas les
règles qui se déroule aujourd'hui
malheureusement
et tout cela constitue quelque chose qui
est quelque peu effrayant pour nous tous
la pandémie a nous a rappelé la
fragilité de la vie humaine est au 21ème
siècle aujourd'hui même dans les pays
les plus les plus développés on voit que
la personne humaine peut se rester
démuni face à sète une à cette infection
qui est donc eu une menace et on voit
que cette crise tous ne touche pas
seulement le domaine médical mais qui
touche l'ensemble des possibilités de la
nature humaine et il est même important
et c'est peut-être encore plus
simplement c'est d'organiser
l'accessibilité de l'ensemble des
activités de notre vie
et ça c'est important nous devons nous
attacher à cela à prendre conscience de
notre responsabilité est face à la
société et expliquer clairement à la
population
l'ensemble des mesures que nous prenons
pour que éviter une division de la
société au contraire il faut pouvoir
favoriser cette cohérence puisque c'est
ensemble que nous pouvons supporter et
sortir vainqueur de cette épreuve
cette crise a montré que dans la montrer
dans cette crise l'importance de l'état
du fonctionnement de l'état et alors que
on avait vu que dans le monde le rôle de
l'état tendait à se réduire au contraire
mais là où on voit aujourd'hui des
processus qui vont fortement évolué à
long terme mais en tout cas aujourd'hui
on voit que le rôle de l'état est
primordial et tout cela c'est une
condition importante pour le
développement de la russie c'est à dire
que le fonctionnement de l'état se
manifeste dans le travail quotidien et
détaillées sur l'ensemble des mesures à
prendre pour éviter de connaître la
situation que nous avons connue dans les
années 90 donc la force de l'état
ici ce n'est pas de d'assumer un
contrôle d'effectuer un contrôle total
de la population
ce n'est pas de chasser les initiatives
privées de la vie quotidienne et même au
niveau des de la défense par exemple
même si on comprend que c'est important
pour la russie mais on a des défis
géopolitiques il se pose aujourd'hui on
a une responsabilité historique en tant
que membre permanent du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu nous avons cette
responsabilité de la stabilité
internationale de la sécurité
mais la force de l'état aujourd'hui
c'est précisément vis-à-vis des citoyens
et pas seulement à l'international
parce que c'est le peuple qui est la
source du pouvoir et est l'objectif de
notre réflexion c'est justement que de
voir si nous sommes prêt à déléguer avec
l'attribution de compétences au niveau
nécessaire aux 18 au différents niveaux
au niveau de nos représentants et tous
ceux qui sont habilités à prendre des
décisions et qui devront rendre des
comptes sur l'exécution du pouvoir et
l'activité qu'ils auront exercé donc
aujourd'hui quelles que soient les
mesures qui puissent être prises c'est
important aujourd'hui que dans le
respect des cultures de lac de
l'héritage culturel que nous avons il ne
s'agit pas aujourd'hui de copier
l'expérience d'autres mais ce qu'il faut
c'est que l'état et la société se trouve
en harmonie et je pense que c'est un mot
clé ici dans la construction de l'état
qui se poursuit en permanence
ce n'est qu'ensemble que nous pouvons
travailler à résoudre et à affronter
tous les défis qui se posent aujourd'hui
une nouvelle fois au pire moment de
l'évolution de cette pandémie
j'ai éprouvé et j'éprouve aujourd'hui un
sentiment de fierté pour la russie pour
le peuple russe qui s'est montré prêt à
lutter ou les gens montrer qu'ils
étaient prêts à céder les uns les autres
et avant tout cette fierté pour tout
notre personnel médical qui sans
exception a fait tous ces efforts pour
maintenir à flot
ce système face à cette menace
aujourd'hui nous cherchons donc que la
loi
la voix de nos si tu as de nos citoyens
soient entendus que les propositions
constructives qui peuvent être faites
soient réalisés mais bien entendu j'ai
une question qui se pose c'est comment
cette demande émanant du peuple et elle
formulé quelle caisse que l'état doit
entendre comment identifier ce thème ou
telle voie pour savoir si elle vient
effectivement du peuple ou si elle n'a
d'autre si elle émane d'autres critiques
venues de l'extérieur qui vont à notre
encontre
donc aujourd'hui cette demande ne doit
pas être remplacés par les intérêts de
tel ou tel groupe aussi bien en
extérieur qu'intérieur mais aujourd'hui
on sait bien que la démocratie normale
ne peut pas être importées sans l'a
souvent dit ça peut être un produit
étranger qui peut être imposée non c'est
pas ça
dans la théorie c'est peut-être possible
mais pour être franc
moi j'ai pas encore été confronté à ce
genre de choses et nous voyons comment
fonctionnent les systèmes imposée de
l'extérieur démocratie donc on a besoin
d'avoir la préservation de notre
souveraineté ici mais les dirigeants
des différentes structures sont pas
seulement son ne sont pas des vassal des
vassaux mais c'est précisément du peuple
doit émaner cette initiative nous avons
vécu une épreuve importante
[Musique]
il y a eu des fonds étrangers qui ont
participé au financement de ces mesures
on nous sommes bien conscients que tous
n'ont pas de mauvaises intentions et
certains qui ont voulu intervenir dans
les l'arrêt de la résolution des
problèmes qui existent ici l'intérieur
et gars effectivement ces organisations
non gouvernementales internationales qui
s'ils ont manifesté un intérêt et un
enthousiasme sincère c'est clair mais
même dans ce cas il y a eu
malheureusement des choses qui étaient
trop étrangère à la russie et on a vu là
se manifester l'intérêt non pas de
citoyens russes mais d'intérêts
étrangers
tout cela entraîne des conséquences qui
sont claires donc il faut que la société
soit puisse préserver sa liberté sa
souveraineté il peut y avoir différents
forums qui utilisent différentes
plateformes de discussion différentes
traditions culturelles propres à chaque
pays et non pas des produits de 10 de
modèles internationaux à politique à un
apatride qui seraient imposées à
l'ensemble du monde non ici nous avons
de nouvelles opportunités qui s'offrent
à nous et je considère que cette
question est importante pour les
autoriser dans l'horizon qui s'ouvre
devant nous et là
on à l'importance de l'action que mène
la russie nous notre capacité générale à
réagir aux défis mondiaux qui se savait
que aujourd'hui ce sont des défis qui se
posent aujourd'hui qui sont parfois
contradictoires et ses défis sont très
nombreux aujourd'hui et depuis que le
modèle de relations de la guerre froide
qui s'était imposée nous ne croyez pas
que j'éprouve une nostalgie vis-à-vis de
ça au contraire j'ai dit plusieurs fois
qu'il faut discuter mais je dirais que
ce nouveau cette nouvelle imposition de
ce modèle qui s'est manifestée si vite
aujourd'hui nous a obligés à analyser la
situation actuelle certains pays se sont
dépêchés d'imposer leurs modèles pour
reprendre la position traditionnelle de
la guerre froide
d'autres pays se sont adaptés à cette
évolution historique et même d'où notre
expérience qui franchement on n'a pas
été toujours amusante nous a poussés à
chercher encore une fois à maintenir
notre liberté notre souveraineté
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent
l'humanité
comment aménager l'ordre international
ici pour continuer à avancer
comment coordonner nos actions et en
évitant un travail égoïste où chacun est
replié sur soi
donc c'est votre votre club justement de
discuter sur ces questions aujourd'hui
on voit quand le contexte international
évolue les institutions sont forcé
d'évoluer
donc on a un système un nouveau système
de relation qui doit se construire
l'auteur de ce rapport dit que un
certain nombre d'institutions vont
fonctionner de façon beaucoup plus
autonome que par le passé qu'est ce que
je voudrais dire à partir de ça bien
entendu nous comprenons bien ce qui est
à la base de cette vision c'est à dire
que l'ordre du monde
l'ordre mondial qui s'est installée
après la deuxième guerre mondiale avec
l'urss les etats-unis la grande-bretagne
le ss n'existe plus la grande bretagne
évoluer les états unis ont évolué est
certain aussi déminer complètement la
russie mais je vous assure cher ses
interlocuteurs que nous étudions en
détail nos capacités nos capacités
économiques territoriales et militaires
et les capacités que nous avons
aujourd'hui nous cherchons à les
renforcer
parce que quand on voit ce qui se
produit dans le monde dans d'autres pays
et je voudrais dire à ceux
qu'ils attendent l'étouffement
progressif de la russie si vous attendez
comme ça j'espère que vous prendrez pas
trop froid attendre mais nous nous
continuons à travailler avec les experts
avec les analystes
mais nous disons que les structures dans
nos salles qui existent doivent être
complètement repensé et reconstruite
voire éliminer dans certains cas mais en
tout cas il faut maintenir le mécanisme
principal de discussion dans nos
relations
il s'agit de l'onu du conseil de
sécurité et des droits de veto de ses
membres je lai encore dit récemment pour
l'assemblée générale de l'onu
il faut maintenir ces fonds dans ses
fondements du droit international mais
l'idée même de corriger les institutions
internationales me paraît en tout cas au
minimum digne d'intérêt digne d'être
discuté de façon à ce que les états
puissent formuler leurs préférences et
je dirais que c'est la leçon des 30 40
dernières années
et comme je viens de dire il n'ya plus
du rss il est est la russie mais par son
poids économique par son influence
politique par son il y à la puissance
chinoise qui existe et on voit aussi
l'allemagne acquérir de la puissance on
voit que l'allemagne joue un rôle de
plus important au niveau international
mais on voit aussi la même chose
pour la grande-bretagne et la france et
des états unis qui à une époque était
avait une position résolument dominante
aujourd'hui on voit cette position
évoluer
voyons comment ça peut évoluer mais on
voit d'autres pays comme le brésil
l'afrique du sud dont le rôle ne cesse
de croître
on voit bien que toutes les
organisations internationales ne sont
pas aujourd'hui abda assurer leurs
missions il ya un certain nombre de d'à
priori idéologiques convoi et certains
pays deviennent des instruments dans les
mains de certains groupes les
manipulations se font plus nombreuses et
notamment quand il ya des pays
concurrents ou des pays
en tout cas compétiteurs mais on voit la
situation qui évolue et on voit se
manifester des égoïsmes des campagnes
politiques médiatiques contre tel ou tel
dirigeant tel ou tel pays et cela ne
fait que renforcer la crise de la
communauté internationale et en même
temps il ya aussi des expériences
positives
là où certains pays unissent leurs
efforts pour résoudre des problématiques
concrètes
par exemple l'organisation de
coopération de shanghai qui depuis déjà
2 dizaine d'années cherche à renforcer
la coopération sur les conflits
territoriaux par exemple il ya aussi le
format d'astana par exemple qui grâce
auquel nous avons pu sortir de l'impasse
profonde dans laquelle nous étions sur
la syrie rappelons ici
les discussions qui ont été organisées
ici pour résoudre ces questions
donc on a des approches tout à fait
productifs qui ont été vus ici
ce qui est important c'est que ces
formats de discussions non seulement
permettent de résoudre un certain nombre
de problèmes mais ensuite il donne le
ton à de nouvelles discussions
et encore une fois sans démarche
généralisée commune
en tout cas tous les groupes quels
qu'ils soient tous les groupes de
discussion
de toute façon fond on ne peut pas se
passer de cette structure générale
mondiale la discussion et cela est
nécessaire pour faire intervenir tous
ceux qui sont intéressés à la résolution
des différents problèmes qui se posent
notamment quand des processus complexes
sont en mouvement quand il n'ya pas de
capacité de discuter et qu'on voit des
actes tout à fait inadmissible de sans
gêne tout seul ou certains cherchent à
promouvoir leurs ambitions pour écraser
tout ce qui gêne tous les gêneurs
je répète que encore une fois malgré
tout la disparité toutes les diversités
dans le monde
il ya un certain nombre de problèmes
aujourd'hui qui impose de s'entendre de
travailler ensemble entre les états y
ait des problèmes qui aujourd'hui
demandent que les solutions trouvées
trouver se fasse au niveau international
le mondial cela permet de résoudre
certains problèmes régionaux de conflits
régionaux
il ya la question de la lutte contre la
pauvreté au niveau international dans le
domaine de la santé publique par exemple
tout cela ce sont des problèmes
d'actualité le mode année je vais parler
de ça alors des discussions de là à
l'assemblée générale de l'onu
et j'avais insisté sur le fait que c'est
important de pouvoir travailler ensemble
et à long terme
il ya aussi des réflexions plus globale
qui se pose aujourd'hui mais qui en même
temps concerne chacun d'entre nous et
sur lesquels je voudrais m'arrêter
quelques instants tout le monde à l'us
antoine de saint-exupéry et vous vous
souvenez du
souvenirs deux héros principal
le matin se lever se laver et remette de
l'ordre nettoyer sa planète c'est un
travail ennuyeux mais qui n'est pas du
tout difficile et je suis convaincu que
cette tâche ennuyeuse
nous devons la faire tous les jours
c'est le gage de vie pour nos les
générations qui vont nous suivre
nettoyer notre planète pour que les
générations suivantes plus l'habiter
dans les discussions je propose de
poursuivre toute cette réflexion autour
des solutions écologiques qui ont été
avancées et chaque jour je finis ou se
dit que va-t-il se passer demain
mais n'oublions pas que la nature est
vulnérable notamment quand on voit
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
dans l'ampleur que nous constatons
aujourd'hui est donc encore une fois
cette nature et à protéger et on voit
ici une intervention anthropogène
qui vient de l'homme et là il est
important d'établir des relations
harmonieuses entre l'homme et la nature
nous avons accumulé ici des dommages qui
sont considérables qui exige de notre
part une avance une attention accrue
puisque cela va concerner chacun d'entre
nous avec le changement climatique on
voit le problème de la disparition de
mer slota et des forêts etc et le ce
processus ne fait que se renforcer
et il concerne l'ensemble du monde il
concerne l'ensemble de l'humanité et 65
% du territoire donc la diversité
naturelle est importante elle doit être
préservé il faut éviter les risques
directs pour la population et pour nous
c'est devenu un problème de de grande
actualité
on a 80 25 % des surfaces des surfaces l
énergie qui peuvent souffrir de
l'augmentation du niveau de la mer et
tout cela c'est une question grave dans
la mesure où on a une réaction en chaîne
entre différents phénomènes
il ya aussi les rejets dans l'air de
méthane qui contribuent à l'effet de
serre ce qui est 28 fois plus dangereux
que le co2 etc et ce produit va de ce
phénomène ne va pas cesser de
de s'aggraver et donc cette cette
problématique du méthane cei ne cesse de
s'aggraver
donc on a des surfaces émergées qu'il
devienne inexploitables et tout cela est
aujourd'hui préoccupant autre thème un
thème complètement différent que
j'aborde ici maintenant
n'oublions pas que il n'y a pas
seulement des continents géographique
sur la tête mais mais il ya aussi
l'espace numérique et chaque année les
gens assimilent de plus en plus les
systèmes numériques et en fait cette
pandémie n'a fait que simuler ce
processus d'assimilation des
technologies de communication et tout
cela est aujourd'hui relève du domaine
public dont toute la structure du
cyberespace aujourd'hui fonctionne de
façon stable
on a vu que le travail à distance
aujourd'hui n'est pas seulement une
mesure nécessaire
une mesure de précaution mais en fait
c'est aussi une nouvelle forme de
travail c'est une nouvelle forme de
relation sociale et avec le
développement du technologique on voit
que cette nouvelle forme est absolument
nécessaire et les cons circonstances ont
fait que ces processus ont été accélérés
et bien entendu il ya le revers de la
médaille c'est à dire que les menaces
qui résident dans le cyberespace et
s'éteint c'est une nouvelle dimension de
la vie humaine et on a aujourd'hui des
failles énormes dans le domaine
juridique par exemple autour de 7
de ce cyber espace il ya une question de
confiance qui se pose ici aujourd'hui
est ce que je veux dire c'est que à
l'époque de la guerre froide
il y avait il y avait cette notion de
renforcement de la défense de la
confiance qui concernait les relations
entre l'urss et les états unis le pacte
de varsovie et l'otan c'est-à-dire dans
le domaine politique ou militaire mais
je souligne que cette concurrence
aujourd'hui revêt un caractère hybride
qui concerne tous les domaines
d'activité de la vie et donc cette
conférence doit être renforcée sur tous
les plans et donc le cyberespace doit
être constitué un espace de décès pour
ce renforcement de la confiance non
comprenons bien que c'est difficile de
mettre en place tous les instruments
nécessaires à assurer cette sécurité
mais c'est maintenant qu'il faut
travailler à cela je vous rappelle que
la russie a été très actif pour
promouvoir différents accords
multilatéraux bilatéraux sur ce plan
nous avons mis en place des groupes de
travail tout à fait ouverts qui
travaillent dans ce domaine nous avons
formulé des propositions aux états unis
pour pouvoir traiter dans la leur
totalité de ces questions nous
comprenons bien que la campagne
politique la campagne présidentielle aux
états unis aujourd'hui
april a priorité sur dans l'ordre du
jour aux états unis et que seuls les
relations avec les désigne aujourd'hui
sont aujourd'hui se pose aujourd'hui
sous un jour particulier mais il ya la
question des armements mais il ya aussi
d'autres questions qui se posent
aujourd'hui et vous savez très bien que
les sujets de discussions aujourd'hui
sont très nombreux et que la russie est
toujours ouverte et prête à discuter
est ce qui est important c'est que dans
toutes les questions qui se posent à
l'international peut être discutée entre
moscou et washington
mais nous espérons bien que la remise le
relancement le redémarrage de ce
dialogue bilatéral permettra de mener
des discussions beaucoup plus large que
simplement entre nos deux pays dans le
cadre de différentes organisations et si
les états unis veulent travailler dans
ce sens nous sommes toujours ouverts
nous sommes toujours prêts mais j'espère
que ce dialogue aurait lieu
je voudrais attirer votre attention
également sur un autre point qui est
important nous sommes dans une période
de dévolution très forte
les jeudis notamment pour les
générations qui ont connu la guerre
froide et aussi les anciens combattants
de la deuxième guerre mondiale
donc tout cela pour eux c'est pas
simplement une question de mémoire c'est
une partie de leur vie et aujourd'hui la
vie humaine a atteint un niveau de
développement social économique
particulier qui fait qu' on a un peu une
dissolution des valeurs auxquelles nous
étions attachés
jusqu'à présent et qui constituait notre
le
le sens de la vie et donc cette crise ne
se résout pas seulement par des
discussions diplomatiques ou des menaces
mais ça veut dire que nous devons revoir
l'ensemble des objectifs qui ceux qui
sont les nôtres c'est à dire que c'est
une discussion qui doit se faire au
niveau de l'ensemble de la société au
niveau de chacun de nous pour ensuite
débordé sur le plan international la
pandémie de commande un virus qui nous a
obligés aujourd'hui à prendre comme
point de repère de nouvelles bases
nous avons besoin de réfléchir à
l'avenir tels que se présente
aujourd'hui et nous comprenons tous à
quel point c'est important je suis
d'accord avec tous ceux qui disent que
qui vaut mieux commander ce commencé ce
processus de révision tout de suite
et rappelons-nous l'expérience des
générations qui nous ont précédés tout
ce dont nous allons parler aujourd'hui
c'est surtout la génération qui monte et
qui va falloir qui va devoir s'en
occuper et nous avons parlé de beaucoup
de ces deux thèmes aujourd'hui et que
tous les citoyens de la russie qui
grandissent aujourd'hui dans le 21e
siècle c'est eux justement de faire des
choix pour l'avenir est de répondre à
des défis peut-être plus compliqué que
ce que nous avons connu dans le passé et
donc c'est le gage de la vie de notre de
chacun d'entre nous pour l'avenir mais
ce qui est le plus important ce qui est
la priorité c'est une meilleure qualité
de vie c'est le patriotisme la capacité
créatrice de la capacité de travailler
détenait le monde autour de nous d'être
exemplaire pour résoudre les tâches les
plus compliqués qui se posent à nos
chers amis chers collègues je parle
aujourd'hui de problèmes tout à fait
divers et bien entendu quand je vois
toutes ces difficultés
je voudrais croire que le monde est
capable de s'unir de se montrer cohérent
pour les face aux menaces pas
imaginaires menace concrète aujourd'hui
et renoncé à l'ambition à l'égoïsme
aux vues étroite mais la question qui se
pose est ce que c'est pas une utopie
tout ça est ce que c'est qu'un voeu
pieux
et quand on voit les propos de certains
représentants de l'humanité aujourd'hui
on a parfois évidemment des doutes sur
le fait que c'est possiblement en tout
cas j'espère que le bon sens et la
compréhension mutuelle prendront le
dessus et que chacun pourra ouvrir les
yeux mais comprendre que la terre l'air
l'eau tout cela il nous appartient c'est
notre héritage à tous c'est ce qui
n'était donnée d'en haut et que nous
devons le préserver de même que la
valeur de chaque vie humaine et dans le
monde complexe qui est le nôtre on ne
peut pas faire autrement je ne voudrais
pas que les erreurs du passé se répète
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci monsieur poutine
merci pour votre intervention détaillé à
venait de dire que la pandémie doit
devenir un point de repère pour le
nouvelle réflexion je vois que
vous avez déjà eu cette réflexion parce
que vous parlez de notre mission sur la
planète de la confiance et on ne parle
pas souvent de choses pareilles je
voudrais après avoir un tas de choses
que vous avez dit précisé bien sûr il ya
une certaine réflexion est ici au sein
du club de valdahon c'est de le faire
aussi mais après l'échec du printemps
quand il semblait que le monde ne
viendrait jamais à la normal on a eu
l'impression qu'il y avait une certaine
stabilisation
et puis on a vu que l'ordre du jour
mondial n'a pas changé les conflits on
voit le retour et même à une
multiplication et malgré les conditions
qui nous limite un peu sur la scène
internationale vous poursuivez vos
activités
les est ce que pour vous c'est vraiment
un bouleversement est est-ce qu'il ya
des changements pour vous et pour vos
collègues vous venez de dire que les
conflits sont revenus en fait il n'avait
pas disparu mais aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de deuxième vague
du fait que l'on se retrouve au même
état que ans au printemps dernier mais
voyez ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
dans le haut karabagh et nous il ya pas
seulement les conflits il ya aussi cette
nécessité de se battre contre cette
pandémie
on nous impose la la que la cohésion et
en fait on voit toujours ces conflits au
moyen-orient en libye en syrie le
terrorisme etc
mais l'écologie aussi donc on voit que
la pandémie va pas nous être utile ici
mais en revanche en ce qui concerne la
prise de conscience que dans des crises
mondiales
il est nécessaire de travailler de
concert tout cela par exemple l'humanité
l'a pas encore compris la nécessité
d'unir nos efforts ne l'est pas encore
tout à fait satisfaite sur la plateforme
de l'onu nous allons parler simplement
des questions d'aspect humanitaires -une
culturel par exemple on supprime toutes
les limites économiques toutes les
restrictions économiques et séchoirs
même pas des sanctions de la russie va
on va se débrouiller je parle d'autres
pays qui ont souffert du cornât virus et
qui continue à souffrir et qui peuvent
même pas recevoir les
l'aide humanitaire des médicaments dont
ils ont besoin des crédits d
l'équipement des échanges de
technologies donc ça relève du domaine
humanitaire de dans son sens le plus
propre
or aucune limitation n'a été supprimé
sur ce plan sous prétexte de motifs
politiques qui n'ont aucun rapport avec
la nécessité humanitaire alors que en
même temps tout le monde dit que c'est
tout le monde se réfère à l'humanisme
donc il faut agir de façon plus honnêtes
les uns vers les autres et renoncer à
tous et un double standard deux poids
deux mesures on voit que les mois qui se
sont passées ils ont montré que et j'en
suis convaincu qu'on leur en le disant
et j'espère que tout le monde va
l'entendre mais je pense que vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que je viens de dire
c'est à dire que chacun dans son coeur
on sera d'accord avec moi mais les
réflexions politiques continuent d'avoir
le dessus
aucune raison de supprimer les sanctions
vis-à-vis de l'iran de la sdat ça
devenait saint mais à cette caisse qui
vient faire ici
alors que c'est le peuple syrien qui
souffrent ici donner des médicaments
donnés de l'équipement technologique les
minutes des des ressources financières
pour le matériel médical n'ont donc par
conséquent d'une part on dirait que les
à un choix qui existe qui est un souhait
de s'unir qui existent mais de l'autre
sur le plan pratique il n'y a pas de
résultats de réalisations concrètes
qu'ils soient visibles même si une
tendance y existe après en ce qui
concerne les technologies c'est un autre
aspect de ce problème
bien entendu effectivement toutes ces
formations en ligne et compris pour la
médecine
toutes ces technologies numériques qui
déjà se fraye un chemin là elles ont
effectivement effectué une percée très
très net donc dans dans ce système de
régulation des systèmes entre les
spécialistes du droit entre un mode de
régulation administrative etc
et tout cela évidemment évolué merci
beaucoup
une question de plus concernant votre
intervention vous avez dit clairement
que la valeur clé c'est la vie et la
sécurité des gens parlant de la
stratégie de lutte contre l'épidémie
la stratégie est claire mais il ya des
il existe des tactiques différentes
au printemps on a entendu beaucoup de
critiques à l'égard des pays qui ont
poursuivi leur propre voix comme par
exemple la suède la biélorussie qui
n'ont pas fermé leurs économies six mois
sont passés maintenant on voit que le
monde entier poursuit la voie choisie
passé dit et vous avez dit hier que vous
n'entendez pas toujours de nouvelles
restrictions de fermer à l'économie
est ce que cela veut dire que l'
équilibre change vers les intérêts
économiques
chez nous ça change pas je sais pas par
exemple en suède où enfin je peux dire
quelques mots en biélorussie ce que ce
que ce produit dans d'autres pays est
assumé par les dirigeants de ce pays
la politique nous avions nous la
maintenons pour nous c'est sans aucun
doute la vie des citoyens est au premier
plan et la vie et la santé
évidemment c'est lié au système de santé
au système de santé public national qui
a besoin de soutien de la part du budget
de l'état et d'autres ressources
budgétaires et bien évidemment pour que
le budget se tienne il faut que
l'économie fonctionne effectivement il
faut trouver un équilibre et je pense
que nous avons réussi des débuts à
maintenir cet équilibre nous avons pris
un certain nombre de mesures importantes
pour le soutien à l'économie ça
représentait 4,5 pour cent du pib mais
la question c'est pas seulement le
volume mais l'efficacité des mesures
prises et il me semble aujourd'hui nous
en avons parlé encore avec le
gouvernement en détail
je dirais que nous avons réussi
ponctuellement en utilisant de grandes
ressources a notamment ses les
ressources qui proviennent de l'activité
des années précédentes notamment au
niveau macroéconomique les indicateurs
macroéconomiques et nous avions tout
cela nous a permis d'utiliser ses
ressources budgétaires de façon efficace
pour les gens pour les familles les
enfants pour les petites entreprises
pour certaines grandes entreprises et
grands secteurs industriels aujourd'hui
on voit qu'on n'a pas en tout cas de
nécessité de revenir aux méthodes
restrictive que nous avons dû prendre
au printemps dernier lorsque nous avons
dû fermer des entreprises envoyer les
gens en congé forcé etc
aujourd'hui a pas de nécessité on a vu
que le secteur médical à fonctionner
très bien aujourd'hui nous avons des
réserves financières on a des
médicaments réserve on a des traitements
qui se sont emparés on a vu comment agir
et donc on a une certaine certitude sur
la façon d'agir
ici ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est que dès le début je
vous le rappelle compte tenu de la
taille de notre territoire nous avons
dit que une partie des compétences
devaient être déléguées aux différentes
entités de la fédération de russie et
est en fait quasiment tous les pays sont
passés à cette méthode ensuite parce que
c'était la méthode la plus adaptée
aujourd'hui cette nécessité ne s'impose
pas on à l'activité industrielle qui ce
qui a repris son activité et on a les
grandes entreprises qui aujourd'hui ont
donné d'excellents indicateurs
économiques
donc bien sûr il y a encore des
problèmes à traiter mais sur le plan
macroéconomique les indicateurs sont
quand même tout à fait honorable sur
l'art est la contraction de l'économie
au deuxième trimestre a été de 8% aux
etats-unis elle était de 9% dans la zone
euro elle était de 14,6 14 7%
vous avez parlé de la suède qui n'a mis
en place aucune mesure de récession mais
on n'a pas la même situation économique
on
on avait d'abord annoncé 8 1%
annie de contraction ensuite bon c'était
au tour de 7,9 quelque chose mais en
tout cas ce que je veux dire c'est que
il ya une politique de soutien à
l'économie
il suffit de soutien à aux personnes et
finalement le résultat de même donc tout
est lié aujourd'hui dans le monde
contemporain dockers un déclin
économique qui est évident ça c'est
clair qu'il est inévitable mais en tout
cas je suis convaincue que vous êtes
bien d'accord avec moi que les mesures
prises ont été le président lukashenko
propos de la biélorussie sur me parler
avec lui on a parlé de cette menace
plusieurs fois évidemment de réserves en
or une telle diversité du paysage
économique et donc il a été obligé de
maintenir la situation économique est en
fait dans l'ensemble sa situation n'est
pas pire que dans d'autres pays dans le
monde
par conséquent nous n'avons pas le choix
la première chose c'est de préserver la
priorité c'est à dire la vie et la santé
des gens nous n'avons pas de nécessité
aujourd'hui d'imposer des mesures de
restriction stricte de fermer les
frontières il ya la nécessité de
corriger le soutien à certains secteurs
industriels pour les pme par exemple
aujourd'hui nous avons des soutiens
supplémentaires à prévoir
peut-être la prolongation des mesures de
soutien qui avaient été proposées
notamment sur le plan fiscal qui avaient
été introduites mais qui doivent
s'achever bientôt là donc aussi des
questions
sur le secteur des transports sur le
secteur des services nous voyons bien
tout cela et nous allons poursuivre
notre travail sur ce plan dans cette
orientation
aussi difficile que ce soit comme je lé
déjà dix ans nous nous appuyons sur la
confiance et maintenant du peuple nous
poursuivrons cette politique de façon à
notre discussion traditionnels
aujourd'hui ce sera compliqué parce
qu'il ya des gens qui sont présents
ainsi dans la salle il ya des questions
que je reçois il y a des collègues et
qui lors qu'ils sont 1 personne j'essaie
d'organiser tout cela est géré s'il ya
des problèmes
désolé ça peut compliquer on va
commencer par la question de timofeï
bordatchev notre collègue par le club de
discussion valdaï
merci pour cette occasion unique à nous
mais c'est pour ce dans le contexte des
bouleversements économiques
nous entendons de plus en plus souvent
la question l'idée plutôt que l'économie
de marché l'économie moderne n'est pas
dans un instrument fiable pour les
étapes pour leur grand pauline sur
lillers préservation et le kop françois
à dire ce manque à le capitalisme
n'avait plus de moyens et de la russie
ça fait déjà 30 ans qu'on habite dans
les conditions du capitalisme
est-ce qu'il faut chercher une
alternative peut-être revenir aux idées
gauchistes trouver quelque chose de
nouveau car marc parlait d
grain de beauté non c'était lénine
pardon qui en parlait des grains de
beauté propre capitaliste donc on n'est
pas tout à fait entrer tout de suite
dans cette économie de marché mais mais
c'est un travail de progressif qui se
fait de mise en place de l'économie de
marché et dans le cas de la russie
donc c'est un travail que nous avons
commandé commencé à partir de du début
quoi 2 0 mais malheureux ceci dit nous
avons quand même
après une période assez longue de
l'économie planifiée c'était évidemment
pas facile de passer tout de suite à
l'économie de marché mais vous savez que
le capitalisme pur et dur dont vous avez
parlé il existait au début du siècle
précédent et après les événements on est
bien connue la première économie
mondiale les états unis dans les années
20 37 après la deuxième guerre mondiale
tout cela a changé
on a déjà souvent parlé au club valdaï
ou pas mais en tout cas les experts qui
connaissent ce sujet mieux que moi on
parle régulièrement c'est que dès que
tout va bien dès que les indicateurs
macroéconomiques
manifestent une certaine stabilité
on dit que l'état se met à gênés en fait
il ya d'autres fonds qui apparaissent et
qui soutiennent l'économie et donc
l'économie et que des cueilli une crise
justement tout le monde se tournent vers
l'état et demande que ses fonctions soit
renforcé et c'est une constante qu'on
retrouve dans l'histoire c'est ça
fonctionne par cycles et ça a été le cas
précédente et crise je me souviens très
bien par exemple en 2008 quand je
recevais la visite des des plus grands
actionnaires de nos plus grandes
entreprises qui était effectivement très
très grande entreprise et qu'ils nous
proposaient leur propriété pour la
valeur d'un dollar d'un or parce que
parce que il voyait qu'ils allaient
margin call qui qui qui jouait ici et
dans cette période on a vu que notre
activité économique fonctionne
différemment les gens ne rejette pas
leurs responsabilités les gens
investissent leur responsabilité
personnelle je suis bien conscient qu'il
ya des gens qui se comportent
différemment mais d'une manière générale
de ce plan social chez nous et je suis
reconnaissant aux gens de ne pas avoir
rejeter leurs responsabilités donc il
n'y a pas aujourd'hui d'économie
purement planifiée prenez l'exemple de
la chine par exemple il n'y a pas non
plus d'économies purement de marche est
donc le rôle régulateur de l'état se
maintient toujours dans l'île par
exemple dans les secteurs mondiaux comme
par exemple l'industrie aéronautique
donc on voit des investissements de
droit de gauche mais il ya quand même un
rôle régulateur de l'état a plus à
donner plus ou moins fort mais en tout
cas tous ceux qui prétendent être des
puissances dans le secteur aéronautique
reçoivent toujours une aide de l'état
tous y est les modes de soutien sont
très divers mais ce qu'on voit la même
chose dans d'autres secteurs industriels
nous devons nous en ce qui concerne donc
comprendre quel est le l'ampleur de ce
soutien de l'état à quel rythme
faut-il le montrer ou faut-il réduire le
soutien de l'état et c'est donc
aujourd'hui certain dj l'état est trop
présent dans l'économie mais après quand
il ya des situations de crise comme
aujourd'hui avec la pandémie quand on
est obligé de d'imposer des restrictions
quand on a le transport aérien qui chute
n'est pas seulement le fret pas
seulement pas seulement pour les
passagers mais aussi pour le fret
donc on a vu ici avec l'aviation où les
passagers voyagent quasiment pas ou très
peu en tout cas là on voit bien que le
soutien de l'état est nécessaire on peut
pas s'en passer
donc il ya rien de complètement
capitaliste où rien de complètement
planifié mais nous en ce qui nous
concerne nous devons comprendre quelle
est la leur rôle est la part de l'état
ici donc il faut être cohérent on peut
pas appliquer bêtement un modèle de
toutous fait je le dit plusieurs fois
quand on a la baisse du bébé dans les
pays dans les économies dites
développées la zone euro 14 % de baisse
du pib
on a eu le chômage d'augmenter mais je
6,3 pour cent ce qui est moins que dans
la zone euro par exemple 1
donc tout ça c'est le fruit de l'action
de l'état du de l'action régulatrice de
l'état nous avons lutté contre
l'inflation
est-ce que c'est pas une fonction de
l'état et si justement la banque
centrale et
le gouvernement sont les acteurs sont
les institutions clé dans le
fonctionnement de l'état notamment la
banque centrale et le gouvernement parce
que il met en place des programmes
sociaux et des projets nationaux
d'investissements des ressources de
l'état et c'est lui qui gère la la
politique de crédit la politique
monétaire avec la banque centrale du
pays donc là on a une inflexion de 3,9
pour cent aujourd'hui et a priori j'en
ai parlé avec la sucette de la banque
centrale nous devrions être dans cette
fourchette autour de 4% tels que ça
avait été fixée donc encore une fois là
on a des fonction régulatrice de l'état
et je suis pris supprimer ça ou
critiquer le rôle excessif de l'état me
paraît dangereux ça me paraît en tout
cas pour l'instant le gouvernement de la
fédération de russie a réussi à
maîtriser cet art particulier une
question de plus ces derniers jours une
vaste discussion concernant l'initiative
du ministère de la finance de réduire
les dépenses sur certains ministères
selon vous est ce que c'est une mesure
pertinente à cause de la crise
le ministère des finances propose cela
on commence à manquer une crise ou pas
il ne cesse de le proposer toujours là
cette volonté d'optimiser les dépenses
et dans l'ensemble c'est presque tous
les ministères des finances qui agissent
ainsi dans tous les pays s'il n'y a rien
d'original
le ministère des finances en fédération
de russie ne propose absolument rien
d'original
donc aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas pris
de décision nous n'avons pas prévu de
réduction des effectifs ou
l'augmentation des délais de service
c'est simplement une proposition du
ministère des finances
elle n'est même pas parvenu en corse est
aujourd'hui une discussion qui se
déroule au niveau du gouvernement
je prendrai une décision définitive en
fonction de la situation économique en
fonction de la situation des revenus de
la population de des membres de la
police de l'armée et cetera du rapport
du pouvoir d'achat de la population et
cetera du marché du travail etc en
fonction de tous ces éléments
je prendrai une décision mais sur le
plan pratique ces questions pour
aujourd'hui ne sont ne sont pas à
l'ordre du jour mais tous les ans des
propositions sont faites très bien très
bien - un résultat de notre réunion les
militaires maintenant peut être calme et
maintenant je voudrais donner la parole
à notre ami qui contribuent beaucoup au
club valdaï center de washington
elle a toujours participé à nos réunions
mais maintenant elle est en ligne
hassen à vous la parole merci fait leur
bonjour monsieur poutine
je voudrais revenir à votre initiative
pour renforcer la confiance dans le
cyberespace
il ya beaucoup de discussions pour
savoir si la confiance est le résultat
de négociations le fait qu'ils existent
et une surgit pas uniquement de la
campagne électorale mais
et à washington beaucoup de gens croient
que la russie travaillent et s'ingère
dans certains domaines est-ce qu'on peut
examiner une sorte de trêve dans ce
domaine pour créer une base de
négociation pour recréer un certain
niveau de confiance en tant que point de
départ pour qu'on puisse mener les
négociations et avoir de résultats plus
considérable et selon vous comment voyez
vous cette trêve digital nous avons
parlé avec les états unis de ces
questions de des questions de
désarmement etc
mais nous avons aussi proposé de
discuter de des problèmes qui se
déroulent aujourd'hui et qui se pose
aujourd'hui pour l'ensemble des pays
dans le contexte plus large possible
vous parlez de cessez le feu de qu'elle
sait ce feu peut-on parler aujourd'hui
on peut considérer qu y en a là aussi
travail on accuse la russie d'être
active de pratiquer l'ingérence mais
nous la russie ne fait pas ça et en plus
les enquêtes qui ont été faites sur
cette question aux états unis notamment
avec un procureur spécial
elles n'ont débouché sur rien du tout on
notamment aux ailes ou encore l ont
montré que une preuve total une absence
de preuves total
donc encore une fois je pense qu'il faut
pas poser des conditions préalables pour
commencer ce discussions au contraire il
faut se mettre tout de suite à table et
discuter nous ne proposons rien qui ne
correspondent pas aux intérêts du
partenariat
si quelqu'un pense qu'il ya de l'un
d'eux la chance va écouter on pose des
règles communes et on travaille un on
met en place un système un instrument de
vérification mais en réalité je
comprends même pas quelle est cette
tendance ces dernières ces derniers le
pendant les derniers mois de la
présidence de du président obama
il y avait des signaux qui avait été
lancée en ce sens mais il ya eu un
changement de président et avec la
nouvelle administration nous avons
commencé pendant presque ces quatre ans
chez nous n'avons pas vraiment con con
concrètement commencé nos discussions et
j'espère que nous aurons quand même la
possibilité de discuter effectivement et
qu'il y aura une réponse positive qui
sera donnée à nos propositions
merci beaucoup le directeur de
l'institut des relations internationales
feux de route alors ski messieurs
poutine dans votre intervention
d'aujourd'hui vous avez évoqué un
problème important de la politique
internationale la maîtrise des armements
au cours de la guerre froide et surtout
sa dernière étape
les états unis et l'urss on crée un
système d'accord de traiter de mesures
de confiance qui établissent le
nombre d'armement et ces derniers 20 ans
on voit que nos partenaires commencent à
demander ce système le traité abm le
traité si elle vers le traité est finie
et maintenant on voit qu'il y a des
problèmes concernant la prolongation du
traité new start
j'ai une question à cet égard selon vous
est ce que le système de la maîtrise des
armements à un avenir à quelles
nouvelles mesures peuvent être prises
je voudrais ajouter qu'il ya un grand
nombre de questions concernant le traité
new start et surtout concernant la
dernière initiative quoi vu il ya deux
jours et beaucoup de questions mais
qu'est ce que cela veut dire
cette nouvelle initiative alors ça va
demander si ce type d'accord ce type 2
traités à un avenir sur les armements
à mon avis le l'avenir n'a pas d'avenir
si on met pas si on pose pas des limites
en matière d'armement et c'est ce à quoi
nous appelons à réfléchir tous nos
partenaires tout le monde sait bien
vous avez numéro tous les retraits des
états unis des différents accords et
traités sur les missiles apporte
intermédiaire sur ciel ouvert etc
mais les américains ont dit qu'ils
avaient commencé cette procédure de
retrait mais sur la base de quoi il
explique même pas pourquoi il dit ils
disent rien les européens ne disent pas
mais ils ne disaient ils sortent pas
mais ils sortent mais vous ne sortez pas
ben évidemment mais vous êtes tous
membres de l'otan donc vous allez
effectuer des vols rapporter toutes les
informations l'otan et nous on pourra
pas le faire
et donc ce que j'ai c'est que on va pas
jouer aux idiots on va rejouer de façon
honnête
en réalité je pense que les partenaires
américains européens des états unis
souhaitent que les états unis se
maintiennent dans ces accords en ce qui
concerne les le contrôle des armements
si on parle de la défense antimissile
les etats unis sont sortis directement
de façon même grossière mais ils l'ont
dit même peu tâtonné honnêtement nous
avouent ils ont trouvé un prétexte pour
accuser la russie de ne pas respecter
ses engagements et pour se retirer de
cet accord si la réalité et elle avait
été telle que ils l'ont proposé il s'en
serait retirée or justement là il ne
s'en retire pas sur le contrôle des
armements
ils font simplement des déclarations
publiques
ils l'ont dit publiquement et c'est tout
mais ne me dites pas que ce que ce sont
des décennies nos sens qu'ils sont tous
blancs non non non
la question du contrôle des armements
nous savons très bien que nous savons
très bien ce qui se produit je sais bien
qu'il ya des sites de lancement de
missiles qui sont fermés qu'il ya des
avions qui sont traités chimiquement
mais on nous dit rien donc c'est donc
encore une fois c'est une chez notre
position c'est leur position c'est à
dire de grandes déclarations publiques
il ya un objectif politique c'est pas un
objectif militaire ici j'en crois pas en
tout cas
mais
le mieux ce serait que ces questions de
contrôle des armements se fasse en
accord entre toutes les parties et que
les accords soient respectés en ce qui
concerne le traité nous sortent quand
nous avons parlé de ces questions nous
avons pris en compte tous les problèmes
qui se posaient il ya une chose qui n'a
pas été traité
c'est ce qui est entre les mains de la
russie comme réponse au retrait des
américains avec notamment nos nouveaux
armements hypersonique de grande
précision
je comprends que tous les pays
travaillent là dessus et eux aussi
seront des abonnements équivalent un
jour ou l'autre on nous dit vous l'avez
mais nous on en a pas mais en tout cas
on en tient compte
il ya aussi le nombre de porter le
nombre de têtes
il ya d'autres aspects aussi qui font
l'objet de discussions mais quel est le
choix que nous avons ici le traité
expire en février prochain
est ce que j'ai proposé
c'est très simple
rien ne se passera si nous prenons ce
prononce prolongeons ce traité d'un an
il va rien se passer mais en tout cas
tous ceux qui ont des préoccupations
aujourd'hui je chaînon examen qu'un
continuerons à discuter simplement et à
trouver une solution
c'est quoi le truc ici c'est que
jusqu'ici nous n'avons quasiment pas
discuté en détail nos partenaires ont
rejeté la possibilité de discuter entre
professionnels sur cette question et
donc on risque de voir expiré ce traité
en février alors qu'est ce qui est mieux
c'est la question on maintient le traité
tel qu'il existe et on commence à en
discuter sérieusement au maintien le
traité pendant un an
ou bien on laisse tomber
ce traité et la russie et les etats unis
et tout le monde reste sans
argumentation son texte juridique sans
base juridique qui permet de discuter et
cela me paraît bien pire que la première
solution mais je le dis et je le répète
encore une fois on s'attache pas on
n'est pas triste paix sur ce traité si
nos partenaires considèrent que c'est
comme ça à bon d'accord on peut pas leur
imposer
mais la sécurité des états-unis de la
russie ne ne souffrira pas de ces
actions des états unis ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que il faut que l'accord soit une
multilatérale on peut inclure nos amis
chinois
nous on n'est pas contre mais laissez
pas à nous qu'il faut
ces panneaux qu'il faut accuser de
refuser de discuter d'un coeur la chine
nous on n'est pas contre est-ce qu'on a
un obstacle à inclure la chine dans
cette discussion mais l'argument que
donne nos amis chinois
oui la chine est un grand pays grandes
puissances avec une économie puissante 1
milliard et demi d'habitants
mais son niveau d'armement est presque
deux fois plus faible que la russie est
alors ils disent alors pourquoi on on se
maintiendrait à un tel déséquilibre
donc c'est le droit
souverain du peuple d'un milliard et
demi d'habitants de construire la
politique correspond à qui vise à
assurer sa propre sécurité
donc évidemment on peut en faire un
objet de discussion est bloqué l'avancé
de toute discussion
mais si on veut inclure la chine dans
ces discussions dans ce processus de
signature
mais alors pourquoi pourquoi seulement
la chine alors et les autres les autres
pays la france par exemple qui comme la
presse l'annoncé vient de tester un
nouveau système de missiles de croisière
et qui est aussi une puissance nucléaire
et la grande-bretagne présent mais à
d'autres puissances nucléaires qui ne
sont pas reconnus officiellement comme
tel mais tout le monde sait très bien
qu'ils ont des armes nucléaires pour
qu'on voit pas faire la politique de
l'autruche ici faire semblant de rien
voir mais non on a besoin de travailler
concrètement d'avancé donc si on veut
assurer notre sécurité
bassong là on inclut les autres pays on
discute
nous ne sommes pas contre la question
c'est simplement de savoir est ce qu est
une base juridique est ce qui est un
objectif que nous visons tous est ce
qu'il ya un exemple à suivre entre par
exemple entre d'accord entre la russie
et les nôtres
donc si vous nous demandez nous ce qu'on
en pense
nous considérons qu'il ne faut pas
perdre ce qu'on a déjà gagné et qu'on
peut partir de la base que nous avons
déjà réussi a été bien que les
dirigeants de nos pays ont pu obtenir
déjà
si nos partenaires ont une autre
proposition et bien nous sommes d'accord
pour discuter oui anatole divine
partenaires qui n'a pas pu venir mais
ici avec nos en ligne merci beaucoup
monsieur le président votre intervention
je voudrais vous remercier de parrot le
concernant l'environnement la protection
de l'environnement et j'ai une question
concernant le conflit dans le
haut-karabagh elle a réussi tout comme
d'autres membres de la communauté
internationale cherche à résoudre ce
conflit par deux moyens pacifiques mais
on n'a pas réussi pour le moment si la
situation se poursuit nous savons que la
russie a des liens étroits tes anciennes
avec l'arménie y compris les relations
militaires
est-ce que la russie va choisir une
partie au conflit et se finir une partie
une autre dans ce conflit avec
l'azerbaïdjan
selon vous est ce qu'il ya des
opportunités positive dans ce conflit
pour la russie car on a vu récemment des
tout conflit entre la turquie et la
france dans la méditerranée sur une
situation pareille peut arriver
la dernière partie de la question j'ai
pas bien compris que vous pouvez répéter
est ce que la france et la russie peut
se rapprocher sur fond de ce conflit
d'accord commençons par le début
au cabba vous avez dit que la russie
avait toujours des liens particuliers a
toujours eu des liens particuliers avec
l'arménie mais on a aussi des liens
particuliers avec l'azerbaïdjan
il ya plus de 2 millions d'arméniens qui
vivent en russie et environ 2 millions
de l'azerbaïdjanais qui vivent en russie
c'est simplement des gens qui sont venus
travailler pour travailler mais aussi
des gens qui travaillent qui vivent en
permanence ici
donc ce sont des milliards de dollars
qui circulent pour le soutien de leur
thé c'est tout cela donc
donc ce sont des liens étroit stable
régulier que la russie aussi entretien
sur le plan humanitaire des relations
d'affaires des relations familiales
par conséquent pour nous l'arménie comme
l'azerbaïdjan sont des partenaires
anciens et pour nous c'est une tragédie
quand on voit les gens mourir il nous
voudrions avoir des relations parfaite
entre avec l'arménie et avec les herbes
ajjan je dirais que dans chaque cas avec
chacun de ces deux pays nous voulons
avoir des relations complètes et nous
voyons quels sont différentes dans les
deux cas l'arménie est un pays chrétien
nous avons des relations étroites avec
l'azerbaïdjan dans deux domaines sur la
composante religieuse j'attire votre
attention sur 15% de la population
la fédération de russie est musulmane
donc pour nous la retire ma job n'est
pas un pays qui nous est étranger n'est
ce que nous ne devons pas oublier c'est
que ce qu'a connu le peuple arménien à
l'époque de la première monte au mondial
et tu la tragédie du peuple arménien c
deuxième point le troisième point c'est
que ce conflit c'est pas seulement un
conflit autour d'un territoire entre
deux pays il a commencé sur une base sur
une opposition ethnique et
malheureusement c'est un fait ces cadets
à sung haïti ou aux par exemple ou bas
dans l'eau car ban des des crimes
horribles ont été commis à l'égard du
peuple arménien et tout cela nous devons
en tenir compte
en même temps nous comprenons bien que
la situation dans laquelle une partie
importante du territoire les abattent
j'en ai perdu ça peut pas se poursuivre
pendant des années des années nous avons
proposé différents types de résolution
de ce conflit pour stabiliser la
situation à long terme
sur un plan économique j'entre pas dans
le détail mais en tout cas c'était un
travail de rapprochement des positions
qui étaient poussés et on pensait que
encore encore un tout petit peu et nous
trouverions la bonne solution
malheureusement ça ne s'est pas passé et
aujourd'hui hélas on voir un conflit
dans sa version la pire et la tragédie
c'est que les gens meurent il ya
beaucoup de pertes des deux côtés vous
le savez d'après les données que nous
avons c'est vraiment des docteurs plus
de 2000 hommes morts de chaque côté on
s'approche déjà des 5000 morts au total
et j'attire votre attention sur le fait
que en dix ans de guerre en afghanistan
l'armée soviétique avait perdu 13 mille
sommes ici dans une main un petit 1 21
intervalle de temps on a déjà 5000
personnes et combien de blessés et
combien de personnes combien d'enfants
souffrent et pour nous c'est une
question particulière donc il ya le
groupe domine ce qui avait été créée en
94 je crois avec la france les
etats-unis la russie en tant que
coprésident avait assumé la présidence
la coprésidence pour ce processus de
paix mais nous comprenons bien et je
suis convaincu
tous les participants de ce processus
sont tout à fait sincères dans leur
volonté de résoudre à trouver une
solution mais personne n'est aussi
intéressé que la russie parce que pour
nous c'est pas semblant sous nos yeux
c'est cédant c'est dans notre recherche
sont nos amis ce sont des gens qu'on
connaît et par conséquent nous occupons
une position qui nous permettrait
d'assurer la confiance avec les deux
parties du et nous vous sommes prêts à
jouer le rôle d'intermédiaire ici pour
que les positions se rapprochent
je voudrais fortement que ce compromis
soit trouvé
comme vous le savez je suis en contact
étroit avec le président aliev comme
avec le premier ministre kényane on se
parle plusieurs fois par jour une
plusieurs fois par jour j'insiste nos
ministres aux affaires étrangères noomiz
de la défense les représentants des
services secrets sont en contact
permanent
on a encore eu la visite des ministres
des affaires étrangères encore
aujourd'hui le 23 ils doivent se
retrouver à washington et j'espère que
nos partenaires américains vont aller à
l'unisson avec nous pour trouver une
solution
et soyons optimistes gardons l'espoir
ensuite en ce qui concerne les
discussions sur les diffusions en
interne dans l'otan entre la france la
turquie
nous n'utilisons jamais dans notre
intérêt les crises qu'il y a
chez nos concurrents nous avons en tout
cas de bonnes perspectives peut-être pas
parfaitement tout cas et il nous avons
de bonnes raisons d'avoir de bonnes
relations avec la la france est aussi
notre coopération avec la turquie qui
est notre voisin et je peux dire plus en
détails dans quelle mesure cet important
pour nous cette coopération entre la
turquie et la russie et la france et la
turquie ce sont des pays qui sont tout à
fait certains mais capable de trouver un
accord monsieur erdogan est un président
suffisamment souple pour qu'on puisse
trouver une c2 et j'espère simplement
que la situation ici se normalisera
gestion le même sujet à il y a quand
même une grande différence qui est un
casting pour cette crise c'est la
participation de la turquie
vous avez dit que monsieur erdogan était
une personne assez flexible peut-être
mais certains croient qu'il essaie
d'élargir sa zone d'influencé jusqu'à
les frontières de l'ancien empire qui
était à l'époque la turquie et qui
comprenait à l'époque la prime est est
ce que nous devons avoir peur que si
poursuit cette politique on peut avoir
aussi des problèmes avec un quart à la
russie n'a peur de rien aujourd'hui dieu
merci nous ne sommes pas dans une
situation
nous avons des raisons d'avoir peur je
ne sais pas ce qu'il en est des projets
du président ado gagnent quel est son
attitude vis-à-vis de l'héritage de l'
empire ottoman c'est lui qu'il faut
poser la question mais ce que je sais
c'est que aujourd'hui le volume de nos
échanges dépasse 20 milliards de dollars
et je sais que la turquie est réellement
intéressé à ce qu'est cette coopération
se poursuivent et je sais que le
président erdogan mène une politique
indépendante sans se laisser influencer
par d'autres il assure le turc ustream
trappe nom ait alors que très rapidement
alors qu'aujourd'hui avec les et
l'europe ça fait des années qu'on traîne
cette question du gazoduc ou voit que
l'europe ne peut pas manifester de
d'indépendance et d'autonomie de
souveraineté pour pouvoir gérer un
projet qui qui va son avantage en plus
alors qu'avec les turcs nous avons tout
faire rapidement malgré tout les
facteurs extérieurs qui peut sauveur
nous avons pris en compte nos intérêts
nationaux
erdogan a dit nous allons faire et nous
l'avons fait et dans d'autres domaines
par exemple dans le domaine de la
coopération technico-militaire
on a fourni à la turquie des systèmes de
défense antiaérienne ce sont les
meilleurs systèmes de défense anti
aérienne au monde aujourd'hui le système
triomphe par exemple et il a dit on
achète il l'a acheté voilà 7 avec un
partenaire pareil c'est agréable de
travailler on travaille de façon fiable
ce qui concerne peut-être quelques
inspirations peut-être concernant la
crimée je ne sais pas et cela ne
m'intéresse pas les intérêts de la
russie sont protégés de façon sûre c'est
pas la peine de vous pouvez ne pas du
tout douter de cela et nos partenaires
le savent très bien ils en sont bien
conscients la position de la turquie sur
le
la non-reconnaissance de la crimée nous
n'avons pas une communauté de vue sur
tous les points c'est clair mais aussi
en ce qui concerne le caucase du sud de
l'encore nos points de vue divergent
souvent mais nous connaissons la
position de l'europe des états unis ce
sont des démocrates inscrits déclaré et
notamment le référendum c'est un
principe de base c'est à dire le peuple
vient il vote
or aujourd'hui j'ignore ce point les
sanctions contre les habitants de la
crise aujourd'hui
cissé n'a qu'une annexion alors pourquoi
ce sont pourquoi ce sont les victimes
pourquoi les sont soudain alors s'ils
ont voté
donc c'est un ces manifestations de
démocratie alors comme on peut les punir
pour leur caractère démocratique c'est
du délire total
c'est n'importe quoi et mais pourtant
c'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
alors il peut montrer du doigt oui oui
tout ça pour dire que
c'est une position cohérente de
d'erdogan il reconnaît pas la grille me
reconnais pas le nagorny karabakh
de notre côté on continue à travailler
avec tout le monde on expose notre point
de vue on fait connaître notre position
et on montre à chacun qu'un autre
position est juste et qu'elle est et si
nos positions divergent à ce moment là
il faut trouver un compromis
par exemple sur la question du sud
caucase
il ya donc des divergences parce que
nous nous supposons que les questions de
ce type là doivent se faire non pas par
la voie des armes mais à la table des
négociations par la diplomatie et on
peut dire qu'effectivement ça fait 30
ans que les discussions se poursuivent
et qui a toujours pas de résultats mais
enfin ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
commencer à se tirer les uns sur les
autres
merci beaucoup oui bien sûr la position
de monsieur attaquant et bien cohérente
mais il reconnaît par exemple
oui oui vous avez raison je suis
d'accord avec vous et je devais le dire
aussi ça mais ça m'a sorti de la tête et
vous le disait bien fait de le dire mais
si je comprends bien la turquie n'est
pas contre le fait que le pays
s'unissent mais c'est simplement le
premier se poser la question
l'unité de ce pays ouais merci anatolie
tuck ou 9 président de l'université mme
dumont sur poutine pour nous tous
l'année 2020 c'est une année des
événements dramatiques et imprévisible
ce n'est pas par hasard
blague peut plaire que si vers la fin de
l'année on
un vus à des extraterrestres à personne
ne sera étonné mais j'ai une question
concernant les éléments qui passe sur le
long de nos frontières pour moi votre
réponse a été très intéressant
concernant la situation dans le caucase
du sud mais en général le long de nos
frontières on voit des événements
dramatiques
par exemple les événements au
kirghizstan
là il y avait toujours des émeutes
autour des élections mais cette année on
a vu une situation particulière quand
même et en biélorussie aussi et en plus
il ya ce problème du donbass on est peut
être déjà fatigué de parler de ce sujet
on connaît bien votre position votre
ferme position sur ce sujet mais j'ai
une question suivante quels sont les
objectifs de notre politique sur
l'espace postsoviétique
car cela affecte notre sécurité et nos
lignes au ministère un lien humaine vous
avez souligné entreprises que les
peuples du caucase
pour nous ce ne sont pas vraiment des
peuples étrangers on peut dire la même
de la biélorussie de l'ukraine et
d'autres pays mieux que tout le monde
vous êtes un spécialiste et vous
connaissez bien politique dans l'espace
de la coi est aujourd'hui une part
considérable de notre politique
extérieure et tous les pays que vous
avez numéraire et d'autres pays avec
lesquels nous avons de bonnes relations
les relations multilatérales et les pays
avec lequel nous avons des discussions
des situations peut-être en forme de cul
de sac malheureusement mais en tout cas
ce pays nous sommes une leçon cher et
nous cherchons justement ce sont des
pays avec lesquels nous avons des
relations depuis des siècles le
potentiel est énorme sur les plans
économique politique on parle tous la
même langue
dans un sens ou dans un autre
à plus ou moins grande échelle
nous sommes tous les représentants d'un
même espace culturel nous avons une
histoire commune
nous avons la victoire sur le nazisme
selon nos nos parents nos grands-parents
assurer cette victoire est aujourd'hui
quelle que soit la situation quelle que
soit la conjoncture économique politique
aujourd'hui on a une communauté
d'intérêts qui est ici et qui doit nous
permettre de renouveler nos relations
quelles que soient les péripéties
qu'elle puisse connaître aujourd'hui
c'est évident quand il y à
l'effondrement de notre état à la fin de
l'urss les gens qui en sont la cause
aurait dû réfléchir aux conséquences
qu'ils allaient s'en suivrait c'est
évident que les
les pays voisins avait aussi une
communauté d'intérêts mais aussi des
diverses désintérêt diverses
je pense ça veut pas dire qu'on va
forcément trouver des solutions aux
problèmes qui se posent
mais il ne faut pas non plus jeter de
l'huile sur le feu il faut pas non plus
insisté mais chercher concrètement ce
que nous avons de commun
quels sont les intérêts communs dans le
domaine de l'intégration économique par
exemple qui n'est pas intéressé
aujourd'hui à ce que du point de vue
technique nous sommes tous nos
concurrents
il n'ya qu'eux qui ne sont pas
intéressés à cela tous les pays de
l'espace postsoviétique ne peuvent pas
ignorer en tout cas les gens
intelligents que unir nos forces
unir nos enfants des infrastructures nos
systèmes énergétiques nos systèmes de
transport la langue commune qui existent
encore et c'est tous ces points
tout cela ce sont des avantages
concurrentiels très important que dans
certaines structures d'intégration
économique dans le monde
il faut des dizaines d'années pour les
tensions alors que nous nous avons ça
entre les mains
nous pouvons l'utiliser ce et c'est un
avantage pour nous tous c'est un
avantage certain
s'ils regardaient en ukraine par exemple
pour en 2014 si cette révolution avec un
coup d'état le résultat regardez la
statistique
simplement des services statistiques la
chute de la production comme s'il avait
eu plusieurs fois la pandémie certains
secteurs industriels qui était la fierté
de toute l'urss et pas seulement de
l'ukraine là les constructions
aéronautiques par exemple les
constructions navales
la construction de missiles de fusée qui
a été construit par des parts des
générations entières
deux citoyens et qui était la fierté et
de l'urss et la fierté de l'ukraine
concrètement tout cela a quasiment
disparu
on voit une la désindustrialisation de
l'ukraine c'était une des républiques
voire peut-être la plus industrie bon à
part peut-être lors à la lavande la
russie la saint pétersbourg moscou etc
mais c'était le crâne était plus
industrialisés est tout seul et perdu
donc c'est complètement stupide ceux qui
ont provoqué cela ils sont complètement
stupide et j'espère bien que ses
intérêts communs triompheront que le bon
sens triomphera on a vu ces processus de
turbulences mais je voudrais attirer
votre attention sur le fait que quand
vous voulez voir la russie ne se mêlent
pas des processus qui se déroule dans
ces pays et j'espère bien que personne
ne va pratiquer l'ingérence ici pour
défendre tel ou tel intérêt dans ses
confits et imposer telle ou telle
discussion au peuple russe je l' ai déjà
dit de momo de voiture rien de ce qui
peut venir de l'extérieur ici ne peux
apporter quelque chose à notre peuple
ça ne va pas fonctionner ici il sans
compter la spécificité de notre culture
de notre histoire et c'est donc que les
biélorusses eux mêmes se se sort de
cette situation qu'ils trouvent une
solution
peut-être peut-être en adoptant des
amendements à la constitution et le
président location de colas 10 et même
bien et peut-être qu'il peut modifier la
constitution à sa faveur et ça n'a rien
à faire avec la démocratie
mais évidemment on peut avoir un regard
sceptique sur tout ce qui se produit bon
je vais pas m'attarder là dessus mais ce
qui s'est produit en biologie et est
plutôt bien par rapport à ce qui s'est
passé dans d'autres pays dits
démocratiques avec les répressions
mesure et cédera de la police mme mais
dans l'ensemble si on construit on
compare si on regarde la carte personne
qui a tiré dans le dos de quelqu'un
d'autre par exemple un bon donc encore
une fois avec sérénité
regardons cette situation pour la
kirghizie le kirghizstan c'est pas mal
évidemment c'est un problème mais si un
[Musique]
changement de régime
peut-être mais tout cela est révélateur
du fait que
dans beaucoup de ces pays
ce cpu en sont encore à la formation de
la structure de l'état
ils sont une étape de développement de
l'état qui est différente et je l' ai
déjà dit à mes collègues
là plusieurs reprises pour tout
l'ensemble des pays de l'espace
postsoviétique faut être
particulièrement attentifs et prudents
quand on soutient c'est nouvelle
formation d'état il faut pas imposer des
schémas venus de l'extérieur ne faut pas
imposer ses recommandations c'est très
important d'éviter toute ingérence parce
que cela casse
sap le processus fragile d'élaboration
de l'état donc faut laisser aux gens la
possibilité de construire eux mêmes au
sein de leur société
ce nouveau ce ce nouvel état et non pas
intervenir comme un éléphant dans un
magasin de porcelaine
donc il faut ici
en cherchant par exemple en soutenant
telle ou telle partie non les cahiers ce
temps son parti de l'hôtesse et les
accords sur le résident nous avons
beaucoup aidé le kirghizstan à se mettre
sur pied ce sont des centaines de
millions de dollars pour la l'adaptation
industrielle du tir existant dans le
système eurasiatique
donc nous avons beaucoup aidé des
entreprises des secteurs économiques
c'est à peu près 500 millions de dollars
de projets qui ont été soutenus sans
parler des systèmes de subvention de
bourse qui ont été proposées ce sont des
dizaines de millions de dollars
mais bien entendu évidemment on peut pas
ne pas être inquiète en voyant ce qui se
passe mais encore une fois on leur
impose pas nos conseils on cherche pas
un soutenir telle ou telle formation
politique mais je pense que dans ce pays
petit à petit les choses vont s'arranger
et le kirghizstan
on continuera à être un pays qui va vers
la prospérité c'est la même chose pour
la moldavie
connaissant les nécessités économiques
politiques je le souhaite des mots creux
de démocratie chez les môles d'avancé
mais en même temps le vin moldave si on
a besoin en france on va boire du vin
moldave en europe européenne on va boire
de vin
voilà donc
est ce qu'on imagine l'entrée de ce
marché la hausse 1,2 de l'union peine
mais il n'ya pas que le vin il ya
d'autres secteurs
la moldavie est tellement lié à la
russie que je vois pas comment on peut
arracher ces liens de même qu'il ya des
productions qui ne sont pas nécessaires
pour le marché russe on a vu ce qui
s'est passé avec le cas donc nous
espérons bien que aux prochaines
élections là le peuple moldave
appréciera les efforts qu entreprend le
président actuel en moldavie pour celles
pour établir de bonnes relations avec la
russie
il a participé à toutes les sessions
merci beaucoup fender un monsieur le
président permettez moi de vous poser
une question qui est lié à une personne
qui n'est pas utilisée par le chrome
l'enjeu parle d' alexeï navalni mais
fait rémy directeur du centre carnegie à
moscou a dit à l'empoisonnement dans
militants de l'opposition russe alexeï
navalni a été un point
deux changements dans les relations
russo allemandes et cela veut dire que
l'allemagne et la chancelière allemande
a joué un rôle particulier avant mais
maintenant cela ce rôle particulière est
dans le passé et la russie aura la même
relation avec l'allemagne que avec
d'autres pays de l'union européenne est
ce que vous partagez cela est ce que
l'allemagne avant jouer un rôle
particulier dans leurs relations avec la
russie
et deuxièmement selon vous est ce que
c'est un moment de grand changement et
si c'est vraiment comme ça qu'est ce que
la russie peut elle faire pour changer
cette tendance
où est-ce qu'on doit jeu juste s'avancer
je vais commencer par le début de votre
question sur l'empoisonnement
nous avons entendu ici là bas toutes
sortes d'accusations sur voila si la
personne dont vous parlez de dire si on
avait voulu effectivement si les
autorités ont voulu éliminer quelqu'un
je vois pas pourquoi on l'a renvoyé en
allemagne
donc dès qu'on m'a demandé si on pouvait
le le le faire évacuer
je pense qu'on a évidemment on aurait pu
l'empêcher de partir de partir puisqu'il
va y avoir une enquête en cours
il avait des limitations il pouvait pas
quitter le pays donc j'ai demandé au
procureur général de le laisser partir
ensuite on nous a dit que des traces de
nos vies de choc avait été trouvé ce
poison qui est maintenant bien que
demain
alors bon entendu d'accord montrez-nous
des éléments qui prouvent les
les matériaux biologiques et les
conclusions médicales pour que plus
selon nous à notre tour les étudier et
que nous ayons une base juridique
officiel pour une enquête jeudi
qu'est ce que nous avons demandé d'
extraordinaire ici donc le procureur
général a demandé à ses homologues
officiellement en allemagne de nous
fournir ces éléments pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'il ya d'extraordinaire ici et avec
une des discussions que j'ai eues avec
un des responsables européens j'ai dit
que peut-être qu'avec avec les
spécialistes allemands ou français
suédois nous nous spécialisons puis
travailler ensemble qu'on puisse
travailler à partir de ces magnan
matériaux pour de lancer une enquête
criminelle et mener une enquête
et pourquoi nous ne nous donne rien
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer
pourquoi y'a aucune explication qui ne
nous est donné tout ceci se déroule de
façon très très curieuse d'accord
ensuite donc on ne dit on a trouvé après
cette race de nos vies chuck s'était
transmis à l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques ont
dit non c'est pas du novice choix que
c'est autre chose
alors cette nourriture que scepanovic
choc on commence à avoir des doutes l'a1
sur ce qui nous est alors faisons une
enquête ensemble je le dis maintenant et
si c'est le cas à ce moment là enfin
d'intérêt oui malheureusement nous avons
eu des cas où il ya des des attentats
qui ont été commis condé contre des
hommes d'affaires des responsables
politiques
et tout cela fait l'objet d' enquête les
responsables sont trouvés ils sont punis
et nous sommes prêts à travailler ici
c'est le cas donc complètement en ce qui
concerne des personnes concrètes ici pas
mal de gens comme sa tâche fut les uns
mais je pense pas que s'échangent
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il prévoit une
transformation est ce qu'ils vont se
transformer en personne qui vont
vraiment faire de la politique et pas
seulement faire du scandale à droite à
gauche mais tout ça c'est où après tout
ce qui concerne l'opposition informelle
dans beaucoup de pays
il ya beaucoup de partis politiques qui
domine et c'est tout regardez ce qui se
passe dans la rue chez eux
donc nous allons continuer à donner à
toutes les forces politiques la
possibilité de travailler dans le cadre
de la loi existence de la loi en vivent
après l'allemagne avec l'allemagne nous
avons toujours de bonnes relations après
la guerre cela est lié à de mon point de
vue un l'existence une certaine période
qui à l'époque de la rda qui était le
principal allié de l'urss et nous avez
des bonnes relations au niveau
le plus bas comme aux niveaux économique
politique etc et il ya toujours beaucoup
de gens qui éprouvent de la sympathie
pour la russie nous apprécions cela et
dans l'allemagne réunies il faut savoir
que la réunification de l'allemagne
la position de l'urss a été importante
ici tel été décisive et est certain de
certains de vos alliés vous l'allemagne
se prononcer contre la réunification à
l'époque
tout cela est et dans les archives or
l'union soviétique a joué un rôle et je
considère personnellement que c'était
une bonne chose parce que on peut pas
diviser ce qui doit être unie et qu'en
l'occurrence le peuple à une volonté
d'unification
il faut pas faire mettre un frein à
cette volonté cela net avantage pour
personne après la mise en place des
relations entre l'est et l'ouest ça
c'est la sphère des allemands eux mêmes
si l'allemagne peut être joué un rôle
d'intermédiaire entre la russie et
d'autres pays pour la la russie n'a pas
besoin d'intermédiaire à l'international
en même temps on a toujours eu des liens
économiques culturels est ce que
l'allemagne veut jouer un rôle
particulier non je pense simplement
c'est l'allemagne qui a son intérêt elle
même est aujourd'hui l'allemagne occupe
la deuxième place pour les échanges
le volume des échanges aujourd'hui elle
est dépassée et même doubler par la
chine enfin en tout cas il ya des
milliers d'entre eux mais les
d'entreprises à capital allemand qui
travaille sur le territoire de la russie
il ya un gros voleuse de
d'investissement et il ya un intérêt
manifeste chez des entrepreneurs
allemands a travaillé avec la russie
parce que ce sont des gens tout à fait
sincère qui veulent sincèrement de
bonnes relations avec notre pays et je
rencontre régulièrement des
représentants des milieux d'affaires
allemands et moi en tout cas moi
personnellement je les considère tous
comme des amis je pense qu'ils le sont
et le travail dans ce sens assure des
millions d'emplois dans l'allemagne même
parce que les produits qui sont
fabriqués en allemagne sont distribués
ensuite en russie est donc tout ça ce
sont des garanties d'emploi on a une
coopération dans beaucoup de secteurs
qui est fortement développée et tout
cela je dirais que c'est ce qui
caractérise caractérise nos relations
justement c'est ce côté réciproque
cet intérêt réciproque qui est qui
constitue la base de nos relations et
non pas l'intérêt de tel ou tel parti de
le tirer avantage de l'autre nom est
certain c'est un intérêt réciproque qui
ne va pas disparaître quel que soit le
contexte politique quelle que soit
l'orientation politique qui sera choisi
et nous allons maintenir et entretenir
de telles relations
merci beaucoup
on reste en europe est allé à tort de
rome
natalia à vous la parole merci monsieur
le président pour moi c'est un grand
honneur de participer à cette session
on parlait de l'importance de l'état et
vous avez également évoqué que le fait
que dans les problèmes par exemple avec
l'environnement on ne peut rien faire
sans l'état
j'ai une question quand même sur le
conflit dans le haut-karabagh nous
espérons tous qu'il y aura un nouveau
cessez-le-feu et qu'on va atteindre de
résultats réels mais actuellement on
voit que le format et trilatérales le
groupe de travail bilatéral n'a pas
donné aucun résultat
et ça fait déjà des années qu'on n'a pas
attendu aucun résultat a peut-être
faudrait-il revoir le format de cette
structure est une autre question
concernant l'énergie et la
transformation énergétique actuellement
l'union européenne mais la grande
travail dans ce domaine et environ 40%
de la de l'énergie doit être générée par
de nouvelles sources les sources dites
vertes et on sait que la russie dépend
beaucoup des
de l'exportation des ressources
naturelles et pour la russie c'est un
grand facteur pour le développement de
son économie dans votre intervention
vous avez parlé de l'importance de
l'opep plus est on sait que la russie a
joué un rôle considérable dans la
stabilisation des prix peut-être hall la
réduction de l'extraction
mais compte tenu de la deuxième vague de
l'épidémie
on croit que la demande sera quand même
assez basse
est-ce que vous allez réduire la
production encore une fois pour
stabiliser de nouveau les prix alors au
début de votre question qu'ils posent ce
qui portait sur le format du
du groupe de minsk est ce qu'il faut le
réformer donc pas donc sa ville natale r
je n'ai pas de réponse concrète à votre
question
malheureusement pour un certain nombre
de raisons objectives
c'est pas que je pas forcément
promouvoir là aussi mais la russie elle
est là elle est à côté
la rue 6 face à ses voisins nous avons
une relation particulière avec ses
voisins nous avons une influence
importante
je les dis on a on a de plus de 2
millions d'arméniens qui vivent en
russie environ 2 millions d'indiens qui
vivent en russie le transfert des
dizaines de milliards de dollars dans le
pays après il ya les relations au niveau
des marchés au niveau culturel
tout cela fait que c'est une intrication
qui est importante et c'est tout à fait
différent entre les relations avec les
états unis et l'arménie la turquie
l'azerbaïdjan
c'est bien évidemment nous ressentons
aussi une responsabilité particulière et
donc nous devons agir de façon délicate
mais dans ce contexte c'est très
important qu'il y ait un soutien de la
part des états unis de la part de la
france et aussi des autres participants
au groupe de mines c'est à dire 12 15
pays d'ailleurs la turquie ont fait
partie mais il ya d'autres pays
européens donc est ce que il faut
réformer cela je sais pas peut-être
peut-être qu'il faut peut-être que le
format évoluera mais ce qu'il faut c'est
que on trouve un compromis qui soit
acceptable pour les deux parties
je le répète encore pendant des années
nous avons rechercher un compromis
c'est un travail scrupuleux méticuleux
on pourrait dire ce sont des km2
deux corridors nous allons proposer
toutes sortes de choses des changements
de des échanges de territoires et pour
l'instant il ya peu de résultats et et
ça a débouché sur cette strate jeudi que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui j'espère
que c'est ce conflit armé prendra fin la
preuve première chose à faire en tout
cas c'est d'arrêter les combats
elle ne sommes mis d'accord déjà à
moscou mais nous n'avons pas réussi à
maintenir cet accord malheureusement
mais nous allons poursuivre nos efforts
maintenant en ce qui concerne le pétrole
et tout ce qui est dit et la demande
autour du pétrole nous mêmes nous
recherchons aujourd'hui d'autres sources
d'énergie nous sommes un des pays les
plus riches en hydrocarbures ça ne veut
pas dire que nous ne recherchons pas
d'autres
formes d'énergies nouvelles
que ce soit solaire éolienne etc et de
plus nous travaillons aussi à
l'amélioration de la situation actuelle
nous à partir de 2022 ne devons obtenir
que les 300 entreprises qui sont les
plus polluantes
aujourd'hui qui sont principalement à la
source des rejets dans l'air pour
qu'elle passe technologies les plus
modernes les plus d'actualité qui
permettent de limiter les rejets dans
l'air et d'une manière générale dans
dans l'environnement
nous comprenons en même temps que en
2024 nous devons réduire de 20%
l'ensemble des projets dans l'air et je
comprends que ces 300 entreprises et ces
douze villes concernées c'est pas ce
n'est pas que ça c'est l'ensemble du
pays et que malheureusement cette
réforme ne va pas changer tout ce qui va
se passer
b mais ce qu'on voudrait c'est qu'en
2030 c'est que tous les projets soient
réduits de moitié
donc ça c'est un objectif qu'on s'est
fixé et qu'on cherche à obtenir mais je
ne pense pas qu'il soit réaliste si tout
le monde veut être compétitif de
renoncer aux énergies fossiles dans une
perspective proche quand je dis une
perspective proche du peut-être dix ans
30 40 ans 50 ans c'est pas réaliste de
se priver des énergies fossiles et donc
quand on entend dire par exemple
les nouvelles normes européennes en
matière d'hydrocarbures sont introduites
il ya des propositions qui sont faites
ce qu'on peut prendre
je pense que cela est lié à des luttes
politiques
en interne il ya aussi pour l'instant je
sois pas que tout c'est tous ces efforts
débouchent sur quelque chose de positif
mais je pense que c'est pas des buts
générale généraux qui vont on a par
exemple on a souscrit aux accords de
tokyo on a fait tout seul on a respecté
tous nous en nos nos engagements c'est
pareil pour les accords de paris nous
considérons je le suis aujourd'hui dans
mon mot d'introduction c'est dur on a là
par exemple la mer slota qui disparaît
aujourd'hui c'est important pour le
maintien mais c'est important pour nous
aussi
et puisque dans cette zone nous avons
beaucoup de systèmes de transport des
gazoducs des oléoducs de chemin de fer
on a des villes entières des des zones
d'habitation donc pour nous c'est un
problème important
nous nous sommes d'accord pour
travailler là dessus pour poursuivre nos
efforts et au niveau international
aussi pour cette propreté envoyé le
mental mais on peut pas sortir des
hydrocarbures comme ça par exemple on a
l'une des sources qui est très important
mais il ya l'autre il ya l'énergie
nucléaire on peut évidemment effrayé
tout le tout le monde avec l'énergie
nucléaire mais en attendant c'est comme
une des sources d'énergie les plus
propres
alors si on prend par exemple le
transport automobile aujourd'hui jusqu'à
présent en europe malgré tout ce qu'on
peut voir on continue à utiliser du
charbon pour l'énergie thermique
alors pourquoi introduire des
restrictions fiscales à l'utilisation du
gaz ou même des carburants
en plus avec les nouveaux équipements on
peut rendre ça beaucoup plus proche est
ce assez pour donner un avantage
concurrentiel à tel ou tel secteur
d'autres pays qui se trouve derrière les
déclarations de certains hommes
politiques
donc moi je dis que c'est simplement je
suis pas sûr que ce soit une
préoccupation strictement écologique ici
donc nous cherchons une solution qui
soit raisonnable équilibré entre les
intérêts de l'écologie et le
développement économique
en ce qui concerne la demande en pétrole
et les travaux dans le cadre de l'opep
plus nous travaillons avec les
américains avec l'arabie saoudite nous
avons des contacts réguliers au niveau
ministériel et il ya encore quelques
jours j'ai encore discuté avec le prince
saoudien et nous nous avons décidé que
pour l'instant nous allons rien changé à
l'accord que nous avons conclu
nous allons simplement voir comment le
marché va se stabiliser
d'ailleurs j'attire votre attention sur
le fait qu' il est en croissance
aujourd'hui l'économie que l'économie
mondiale a perdu en raison de la crise
mais aujourd'hui la demande en pétrole
augmente la consommation augmente et
nous avons aujourd'hui aucune nécessité
de changer notre accord ceci dit nous
n'exclurons pas de maintenir les
limitations d'extraction aujourd'hui et
ne pas l'élever comme ça a été le fait
en mai mais peut-être que si nécessaire
nous changerions de décisions pour leur
sens en tout cas à l'heure actuelle nous
ne voyons pas de nécessité de changer
la russie n'est pas non plus intéressé
à des fortes variations des prix vers le
haut ou vers le bas
hélas nos intérêts convergent avec ceux
des mains qui est d'abord parce que une
forte baisse
des prix du pétrole notamment le secteur
du gaz de schiste
aujourd'hui va rencontrer aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de difficultés mais les
états unis l'ont bien vu ils se sont pas
ils n'ont pas souscrit à l'accord de
l'opep plus est en fait ils ont réduit
leur production ici quasiment tous les
acteurs du marché ont un intérêt qui est
commun comme disent les diplomates ils
ont intérêt qu'ils sont trop chaud qui
concordent
donc pour éviter de causer des dommages
supplémentaires c'est important ici est
de ne pas causer de dommage à de
dommages aux activités de prospection
dans le secteur énergétique a souvent
dit que tel ou tel acteur est très
mauvais parce qu'il est très polluant et
c'est finalement il a dès que décote
boursière qui sont très bonne donc
donc attention déclarations de ceux qui
ne s'y connaissent pas aujourd'hui il ya
les intérêts des propre pays
il y à des compromis à trouver entre la
préservation de l'environnement et le
développement économique il faut assurer
la capacité à apporter des revenus à nos
citoyens allofamille dans un équilibre
d'intérêt et je pense que entrevoit une
solution toute autre solution conduira
qu'à un échec ces petits pourront
discuter assez régulièrement sans du
club valdaï et je pense que vous avez
vraiment tirer des récentes de ses
pendules et vous avez l'air très
paisible est-ce que cela ne vous insulte
pas le fait qu'un europe
on dit que vous êtes presque assassin
qui impose des sanctions proches
collègues partisans vous devez toujours
justifier vos actions vous savez je suis
atteint par peu de choses
parce que dans l'exécution des
obligations sur le transforme en
fonction mais cette fonction alain
objectif c'est assurer le bien du peuple
russe de nos concitoyens et de notre
pays l'eau reste
j'essaie d'en faire abstraction pour que
cela ne me rappelle pas de d'assurer ma
fonction de remplir ma fonction
déjà à partir de 2000
quand on a commencé à lutter contre les
bandes de terroristes dans le caucase
déjà à l'époque j'ai entendu toutes
sortes de choses on m'avait représenté
avec des gros points tu tu sais cela ne
me trouble absolument pas merci de
shanghai
à vous la parole bonjour merci beaucoup
de c'était unique opportunité
le sujet du forum valdes à cette année
ce sont les leçons de la pandémie et
l'agenda international comment
transformer la crise en opportunité un
jour et modifier un peu ce titre comment
tirer avantage de cette crise car on
voit le long de change rapidement dans
ces conditions selon vous dans ces
conditions comment faut-il dans le pot
développer politiquement et
économiquement la relation entre la
russie et la chine
qu'est ce à quoi peut-on s'attendre vous
savez la question de savoir comment
développer les relations entre la russie
et la chine
ma réponse est simple comme nous l'avons
fait jusqu'à récemment comme nous le
faisons actuellement les relations entre
la russie la chine ont atteint un niveau
inégalé
je parle pas des secteurs privilégiés de
7,1 jeudi en général je parle de la
qualité de nos relations et c'est une
qualité de relations qui fait que nous
avons beaucoup de confiance l'un envers
violente
nous avons établi des liens de travail
sur tous les plans qui fonctionne très
bien avec mon ami c'est le mot que
j'emploie à juste titre le président
jean ping s'est pas simplement que nous
sommes en contact permanent sur la
question de savoir ce que nous comment
nous devons faire mais en fait nous
trouvons toujours le moyen d'avancer
ensemble
vous savez que travailler dans le
domaine de l'aviation de l'énergie
nucléaire dont il vient d'être question
des échanges commerciaux sont 1 milliard
dé change la donne et ce n'est pas le ce
n'est pas le maximum on pourrait aller
beaucoup plus loin nous parle des
infrastructures d'éponger au sens
concret des ponts que nous construisons
des relations de travail des grands
projets là où nous sommes
complémentaires l'inde notamment en est
sur le plan énergétique par exemple il
ya aussi les plans que nous établissons
il ya ce que nous réalisons avec des
des par exemple l'extraction de de gaz
compressé par exemple pas par la
frontière avec la chine mais dans le
grand nord mais nous coopérons aussi sur
le plan international nous en avons
souvent parlé c'est très important de
d'exercer ce rôle stabilisateur sur
l'arène internationale
d je parle pas seulement aussi je n'ai
pas parlé non plus de la coopération au
niveau militaire et technique et là
encore nous avons ces relations revêtent
un caractère traditionnel volumineux il
s'agit pas seulement de vente
d'équipements mais aussi des changes de
technologie et nous travaillons avec nos
amis chinois
dans cette optique dans une atmosphère
de respect mutuel de confiance et de
recherche du résultat maximum tant du
côté chinois que du côté russe qui vient
d'un autre partie est d'ailleurs
shanghai c'est la vie qui est jumelé
jumelée avec ma ville natale saint
pétersbourg et c'est une ville
magnifique que j'apprécie beaucoup et je
souhaite tout le meilleur aux habitants
de la ville de shanghai est une autre
question
partenaire chinois militaire entre la
russie
on peut imaginer peut tout imaginer
partant du fait que nos relations ont
atteint un niveau inégalé de confiance
et de coopération
et je pense pas qu'on ait forcément
besoin de ça mais théoriquement oui
pourquoi pas ça peut être en mai ag nous
menons des exercices navals terrestre
entre la russie et la chine
nous faisons des exercices pratiques en
domaine de dans le domaine militaire
nous avons atteint un niveau de
coopération dans le domaine de la
coopération technico militaire et s'agit
pas simplement d'eux des changes le
produit des équipements mais aussi des
échanges de technologies et là on a des
progressions tout à fait sensible je
peux pas en parler non plus publiquement
mais mais nos amis chinois le savent la
coopération avec la chine est sans aucun
doute
renforce la capacité de défense de
désarmer ruche et la russie bien
évidemment intéressé à cela et la chine
elle aussi comment cela va évoluer à
l'avenir je ne sais pas
la vie nous ment toi mais c'est pas
l'objectif qu'on se fixe pour l'instant
c'est que c'est en tout cas on n'exclut
pas non plus mais on verra
en tout cas nous sommes tout à fait
satisfaits de la façon dont les
relations entre la chine et la russie
s'établissent il ya aujourd'hui une
nouvelle menace qui apparaissent par
exemple la volonté de nos partenaires
américains de placer des armes de portée
intermédiaire dans l'espace de l'océan
pacifique
et là bien évidemment nous sommes
obligés de réagir de trouver une réponse
à apporter à cela c'était concrètement
faut voir ce qui va être fait et à ce
moment là
quels seront les menaces concrètes qui
ce fric et se présenteront devant nous
et à ce moment là nous devrons
travailler avec la chine pour apporter
des réponses concrètes
merci de ta va peut-être à vous la
parole
merci beaucoup sur cette opportunité
unique de vous poser une question vous
avez mentionné dans votre intervention
est que la jeunesse devra développer la
russie et assurer à l'avenir de la
russie mais partout dans le monde de la
jeunesse est très mécontente de ce qui
se passe aux états unis et en france
israël partout ils disent que nous avons
fermé la porte à de bon avenir pour eux
et selon les sondages la plupart des
jeunes estime mc ils vont vivre pire que
leurs parents je voudrais vous demander
en tant que président de la fédération
de russie
quel serait votre
c'est pour la jeunesse russe jeu j'en ai
dit quelques mots dans mon mot
d'ouverture mais je voudrais confirmer
ce train c'est à dire que l'avenir de la
jeunesse est la priorité la jeunesse
en règle générale est mécontente non pas
de ce qui se produit mais deux c'est
qu'elle a obtenus et elle veut toujours
plus et en fait c'est bien et je pense
que c'est ça qui est à la base du
progrès et c'est ça qui fait que les
jeunes font construire mon avenir qu'il
sera meilleur que ce qu'on a vu et là
y'a rien d'étonnant rien de nouveau
nous voyons bien cela par la littérature
russe classique vous pouvez lire et vous
le verrez ce que nous pouvons proposer
nos en partant du principe qu'il faut
donner plus d'opportunités
professionnelles notamment au niveau de
l'ascenseur social et de d'améliorer ce
système de promotion que les gens puce
le jeune plus faire des études poussées
seul en scène carrière obtenir des
revenus complémentaires pour leur femme
est donc un certain nombre de mesures
systémiques de soutien et même en
perdant les conditions pandémie je tiens
sous le nez l'essentiel des mesures de
soutien ont été orientés vers les
familles
et justement c'est essentiellement ce
sont les jeunes et nous allons
poursuivre cette politique parce que la
meilleure qualité de vie pour les jeunes
c'est de regarder l'avenir en toute
confiance
il ya la question de la mobilité des
générations précédentes par exemple
aujourd'hui on a une progression est
donc je pense que les jeunes vont
reprendre
le relais de génération précédente et
poursuivre ce mouvement
merci nous avons aujourd'hui nous sommes
en ligne en direct avec l'australie ce
quelque chose d'inhabituel pour non
merci monsieur le président pour cette
opportunité de vous poser une question
j'apprécie beaucoup vous idées profondes
et intéressante ici à melbourne en
australie nous avons une nouvelle
quarantaine
je tiens à souligner que c'est aussi je
mêle de saint pétersbourg et pour vous
comment vous voulez vous restez dans
l'histoire en tant que dirigeant et en
tant que présidente de la fédération de
russie de la première moitié de la vente
du miel du 20e siècle
comment voulez vous être décrit en tant
que dirigeante en tant que non est ce
que vous cherchez des changements en
tant que président silva
peut-être une erreur de traduction mais
si on vivait dans le xxème siècle mais
21e siècle mais nous vivons dans le
21ème siècle je pense pas en catégories
telles que vous les avez formulées je
pense pas mon rôle dans l'état je pense
que ceux qui pensent à ça on notre
mentalité moi je ne lis pas des livres
sur moi par exemple je travaille je fais
mon travail
jour après jour je remplis mes missions
jeu résout les problèmes qui s'opposent
et je cherche à faire en sorte que ces
petites missions que je remplis au jour
à jour ne gêne pas les grands objectifs
qu'on s'est fixés
et je considère que ce qui doit être
fait aujourd'hui ou demain on a trois à
l'horizon de trois ans et c'est
évidemment nous réfléchissons en
fonction d'objectifs stratégiques et
c'est pour ça que nous avons des plans
de développement nationaux qui sont
mises en place
cela n'est pas lié à ma volonté propre
jeu c'est d'y être à autre chose c'était
simplement à l'objectif de d'améliorer
le niveau de vie des du peuple russe et
après comment le front les générations
suivantes on sent le laissera ce seront
aux générations suivantes de juger mais
mais je pense que cela ce sera très
intéressant pour moi à ce moment là donc
je suis beaucoup plus pragmatique que ça
j'essaie de travailler non pas pour mon
image dirigeant mondial que deere je ne
pense pas me distinguer d'autres
dirigeants dans le monde mais je
travaille au renforcement de mon pays et
c'est mon objectif numéro un c'est ma
raison de ma raison d'être
merci beaucoup je voudrais citer votre
interview avant le vote sur les
amendements à la constitution vous avez
dit que la possibilité de rester au
pouvoir après
l'année 2024 après l'élection de cette
année c'est une garantie que les gens ne
vont pas chercher toujours quelqu'un
pour remplacer représente leurs intérêts
non il faut bien que ce ça va s'arrêter
un jour et j'en ai bien conscience
mais les amendements de la constitution
que vous avez évoqué c'est pas
simplement de donner aux chefs d'état en
exercice est à possibilité de se
maintenir après 2024 ou même plus tard
c'est que c'est uniquement de maintenir
la souveraineté de la russie et qu'il ya
une base constitutionnelle qui est
demeure ici qui contribue à renforcer
notre pays à renforcer sa souveraineté
c'est à cela que je travaille
après ce qui va se passer en 2024 plus
tard sans on verra le moment venu
aujourd'hui je travaille comme saint
françois d'assise a ardemment à ma tâche
de chaque jour merci alexandre ahr au
mieux je parle aussi des choses
nostalgique il ya vingt ans je me
souviens vous avez point c'est votre
discours historique en allemand
bundestag que vous avez proposé une
espace commune de lisbonne à vladivostok
et les français les allemands se tait
yeux c était les l'europe de l'est est
des états unis n'ont pas soutenu ces
petits dés les etats unis qui nous
empêche de développer des relations avec
l'europe
si aujourd'hui vous pouvez vous exprimer
d'estag avec l'intervention est ce que
vous voudriez proposé de coopérer dans
le domaine de numérique mais de créer ce
partenariat avec l'europe
alors pour savoir ce que je dirai si
j'intervenais maintenant dans le monde
en otage
bundestag à l'époque au moment de monde
dix points en 2007
beaucoup de collègues m'ont dit mais
c'est un peu risqué pourquoi c'était pas
bien de dire ça et que ce jeudi je vous
le rappelle je dis que c'est
inadmissible qu'un pays dépassant ses
frontières nationales et cherche à
réglementer tout ce qui se passe dans
les autres pays c'est à peu près ça que
j'ai dit mais qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est ce que ce sont pas les
les leaders ouest européen qui
aujourd'hui disent que les sanctions
américaines que le le caractère non
territoriale des décisions
américains sont scandaleux est ce qu'ils
essaient de modifier cette situation
aujourd'hui son détruire la solidarité
north atlantic et les autres structures
de l'otan et d'autres structures
similaires
c'est pas moi qui en ai parlé mais ça
c'est pas ça que j'ai parlé moi j'ai
j'ai simplement dit que je dis que c'est
nuisible et c'est nuisible pour ceux qui
le font donc à l'époque que ça semblait
ne pas considérer concernés nos
collègues ouest européen et puis
aujourd'hui le temps a passé et comme le
disait tchernomirdine disait ça n'a
jamais existé et puis voilà encore une
fois est donc encore une fois il se
produit ce qui s'était produit alors et
je dis que tout cela est nuisible pour
tout le monde et tous ceux qui cherchent
à mener une politique de privilèges et
d'exception est en fait cela porte
dommages aux états unis eux mêmes
aujourd'hui les les avantages concrets
du jour que les états unis en porte
peuvent entraîner finalement ont des
conséquences plus graves
enfin c'est pas c'est pas mon affaire
nous où se rencontre on discute pour
pour dans le cadre d'un club de
discussion
donc je me permets un peu de philosophie
enfin on voit des choses tout à fait
évidente
donc je n'ai absolument rien de dit
d'exceptionnel d'agressif
à munich en 2007 je pense que si
j'intervenais maintenant j'aurais pas
dit vous voyez je l'avais bien dit
simplement par respect pour mes
collègues mais je comprends les réalités
du monde à l'époque celle d'aujourd'hui
eu des choses qui sont pas forcément pas
toujours très palpable mais il ya aussi
des réalités tout à fait concrète jeu
tout le monde voit bien que il ya une
évolution qui se fait mais on parle de
nouvel ordre mondial mais aujourd'hui on
voit bien comment se construisent des
relations internationales et encore une
fois ils doivent se construire sur la
base du respect mutuel et des intérêts
réciproques ce dans le respect des
souverainetés et j'espère que
tranquillement son cas c'est ce qui a
été construit pendant plusieurs dizaines
d'années
mais compte tenu des nécessités des
impératifs d'aujourd'hui que nous
pourrons construire des relations qui
correspondront et aux nécessités
d'aujourd'hui et aux intérêts de tous
les participants à l'excès katyn
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup parlé de
l'écologie on ne peut pas éviter ce
sujet écoutez ça fait combien de temps
déjà on termine en termine on le voit
que nous avons déjà dépassé de limites
mais on ne peut pas négliger le sujet on
peut pas passer sous silence
merci bonsoir monsieur poutine peut-être
une question à quels
vous attendez pas mais je vous ai vu à
mon entreprise on a parlé déjà de
l'antarctique
on a évoqué ce sujet est aujourd'hui à
la session climatique
aussi et en général c'est l'année 2020
c'est l'année où on célèbre
l'anniversaire de 100 ans de l'ouverture
de la tarte ide et on travaille dans le
cadre de la nouvelle stratégie pour
construire la station vostok dans cette
région est tout peut paraître bien il ya
des investissements dans
l'infrastructure et on peut avoir une
impression que tout va bien avec
l'intérim mais ce n'est pas le cas parce
que ces stratégies porte sur
l'infrastructure mais elle ne couvre pas
la science une situation étrange sorte
de paradoxe on fait des investissements
pourquoi pourquoi at on besoin de
l'infrastructure pour développer la
science mais cette composante clef est
négligée d'un autre institut de
[Musique]
l'interdît nous avons élaboré un projet
pour cette station vostok et via deux
sujets clés étudiés le climat du passé
et cela est lié à notre sujet et l'autre
ce sujet c'est le lac
vostok s'étend des objets le plus unique
du planet nous les chercheurs russes
ici nous sommes assez forts et parfois
on dépasse même nos collègues étrangers
mais en russie il n'y a pas de soutien
en ce qui concerne les recherches dans
cette zone il ya des investissements on
sait que ce projet est en train d'être
élaborée mais quand même je question
très simple le gouvernement russe
peut-il soutenir nos efforts pour
étudier à l'antarctique où est ce que ce
sujet sera négligée parce qu'on peut
presque de perdre notre priorité
alex et oui ce que vous et vos collègues
avaient réussi à vous installer à vous
poser là bas vous avez fait cette
découverte d'eau là sur la station
rostock une eau qui re qui a des
milliers d'années d'existence et qui n'a
jamais été en contact avec l'air ambiant
et qui est placé sous les eaux c
passionnant et je vois que quand des
savons comme vous des scientifiques en
vous et tu dis
l'évolution du climat je veux donc ces
noyaux que vous avez proposé tout cela
est passionnant et donc effectivement il
ya une infrastructure qui est nécessaire
je sais pas dans les détails ce qui
était prévu vous dites que des
ressources sont attribués au
développement des infrastructures mais
pas suffisamment pour la science 2 c'est
vrai que nous avons eu des en raison de
la de la difficulté des difficultés
connues en dans l'économie nous avons dû
réduire les dépenses budgétaires
affectés à cela mais évidemment cela ne
doit pas affecter l'activité
scientifique dans l'antarctique
donc quelqu'un a dû faire une erreur
quelque part mais c'est poutine dans
votre intervention vous avez dit que la
guerre froide ne vous manque pas et
qu'est-ce que vous manque les enfants
oui les enfants montent
je les vois rarement et nous dans le
club valdaï
ça ne manque ce qui nous manque c'est la
possibilité de
se réunir à 1 semble les technologies in
oz mais nous espérons que l'année
prochaine nous pourrons le revoir en
personne nous avons pas battu le record
il ya un forum où vous avez passer
encore plus de temps avec nous mais nous
avons nous avons presque à temps serait
quoi nous avons passé trois heures avec
le président de la fédération de russie
nous sommes très reconnaissants merci
beaucoup
on vous attend l'année prochaine merci à
vous en tant que qu'animateur de ce
débat et à tous les experts aussi et
tous les politiques les journalistes qui
travaillent dans le cadre de cette
structure
parce qu'on voit qu'elle fonctionne
depuis longtemps c'est toujours
intéressant cela présente une victime
une utilité la reconnaissance va
également au fait que ce que vous vous
intéressez à la russie à nos plans de
développement à notre histoire et tout
cela est révélateur de l'intérêt que les
gens pour nous et pour nous c'est
important aussi de connaître votre
opinion et je le dis tout à fait
sincèrement parce que en mettant côte à
côte
nos différents avis nos visions
politiques économiques
nos visions de ce qui est bon et de ce
qui ne l'est pas tout cela nous permet
de trouver des douze des décisions plus
juste ou de rectifier peut-être nos
plans et je tiens à vous remercier pour
cela et je vous souhaite aussi un plein
succès sur le plan personnel et
professionnel je vous remercie
au revoir merci à tous chers collègues
[Rires]